perfetto ci siamo ragazzi madonna sono
carico come una pigna signori allora se
avete aperto questo video adesso perché
comunque rimarrà sul canale questa una
live quindi scappate direttamente a
quando inizierò a giocare che sarà tra
penso 5 di minuti 5 barra 10 massimo
scappate già al punto perché sto
aspettando la gente si connetta per
assistere alla storia alla storia che ci
si parla della storia del videogioco
oggi si parla di folgaria ragazzi oggi
facciamo for guys ragazzi fermi fermi
fermi tutti fermi nella mente come oggi
facciamo il gio
se io avessi fatto youtube bene se sei
folger scorsa su youtube nel 2013 io
sarei diventato più di pipe che poi lo
so di stato lo stesso ma appena questo
feeling sia la nazione leogra sulla
nazione diego grazie per la donazione un
bacio oggi assistete alla storia alla
storia allora premessa velocissima
promesso pre parto
che casino grazie mille premessa
velocissima poi parto
io ho già giocato a folkest perché ho
già registrato il primo video di faul
guys che uscirà domani domani uscirà il
primo video
normale quindi montato di paul guys e
quindi ho detto vabbè aspetto domani e
poi domani esce il primo video di for
guys ok non ce l'ho fatta
non ce l'ho fatta è troppo bello e
voglio giocarlo in live quindi domani
esce il primo video io di roccia tutti
ragazzi benvenuti sono stufo di guys mio
primo video vada quindi quello sarà
effettivamente la prima volta che ho
giocato a fuori guys adesso non è la
prima volta che gioca for guys perché
l'ho già registrato poco fa quindi
domani vedrete il video
oggi ci giochiamo insieme in live quindi
non è la prima volta che ci gioco ma se
la prima volta che lo vedete sarà una
bomba assurda
ringrazio moltissimo federico russo per
l'azione classe handling per la
donazione e alex king per la donazione
grazie ai ragazzi un bacio direi che
siamo carichi si può partire con fall
guys ragazzo allora questo gioco è la
storia del videogioco io non posso dire
nient'altro se non questa è meglio di
così non vi posso portare niente secondo
me questo è il massimo
grazie mille ragazzi grazie alla
donazione oggi facciamo le trovate
allora vi ripeto domani vedrete un video
dove giocano la prima volta venissero un
po più impacciato perché è la mia prima
partita bellissimo comunque sarebbero al
sicuro
guardate il video di domani oggi solo un
po più esperto perché l'ho già fatto
però mi sono avete ancora visto i casi
tratta ve lo spiego
allora non so se avete mai visto
takeshi's cast perché takeshi's kastel
grazie stefano welcome in degiacomi
brother grazie mille un bacio da cashes
castellet un gioco molto simile dove
presidente bisogna si parte che siamo e
sono in tanti di un centinaio e poi si
arriva che ne vinci che vince soltanto
una persona tipo un battle royale che
arrivò forte c'entra un cazzo forte
perché ci sono le armi oggi tra niente è
veramente solo un percorso ad ostacoli
con vari minigiochi che puntano a
diminuire i partecipanti fino a che non
ne vince uno solo la chiara grazie alla
trazione no per laborazione gazzoni
laborazione perché non semi semmai live
mattutine lo dico a posto mega sbaglio 3
2 1 lett cavolo si fa te questa partita
allora vi spiego questo è un semplice
percorso lo stato li bisogna arrivare
alla fine
si classificano come in alto a destra i
primi 30
ok quindi non bisogna arrivare primi
basta arrivare tra i primi 30 è uguale
arrivi prima o trentesimo cambia niente
non cambia assolutamente niente quindi
aspettate che arrivò fino alla fine vedo
che lanciano pacchetto sbaglio langa vi
aspettate che arriva la fine di questo è
ingiusto non so come mai stia allargando
dell'idea ha mai legato termine ci metto
solo un attimo arrivo qua e aggiusto
don't worry aiuto arrivare i primi 3 3
che non piaceva fare ha fatto che mentre
gli altri arrivano a giusto ragazzi non
si mai magari perché dovete ho scritto
non metterò che videro prova a non
mettere schermo intero liscio con me lo
fa fare qua non lo fa fare qua proviamo
a vedere se il codisa scali di attivare
eccoci dai largo zino boh non lo so come
mai allora mettiamo ammettiamo alla
finestra perché magari quello non ho
idea
risoluzione ma parla bene così
[Musica]
ok sto risolvendo era castori un attimo
che non mi aveva dato il suo problema
prima non so come mai è stato dato così
box trans roba è strano che mi laghi che
non ha mai legato anche perché le line
faccio sempre
ok non è insopportabile ma preferiscono
non la gare ti facciamo chissenefrega
salvi sync chissà che il cacchio è
provato a togliere di mettere il piatto
faccio prima a ian so sorry problemi che
tecnici normalissimi come sa in francese
da oggi i ragazzi intanto grazie claudio
o come da giacomo my brother ragazzi
mille tenchi suo march mise anche pesato
la webcam nice
tranquilli di giallo subito all'attacco
e già che ci siamo perfetto and again
polemici fitness ragazzi bella cecilia
grazie mila ragazzi sui leggo tutti ai
che si ritroverà ok non so se sei
risolto forse sì o no e largo sino ma
perché che strano proprio strana sta
roba
vediamo però diminuire il bitrate sarà
quello anche se mi fa veramente strano
cioè non no no non è quello non può
essere mio computer è troppo potente per
sta roba
sarà un settaggio strano prima così
[Musica]
grazie ragazzi adesso vi leggo tutti
erano solo in attivo che sto risolverlo
sta roba che mega utile che si veda bene
ma questo gioco merita se no lo riavvio
e basta vediamo se mi laga tutto
qualsiasi cosa
non penso abbiamo qualcosa cacchio pa pa
pa pa pa pa pa
grazie mille comunque ragazzi grazie
claudio grazie bubble per per la pm per
laborazione fire alberto grazie pedone
shaun simone grazie mille a vela risolva
il volo radio perché non mi va che la
chicca che si veda la calma nel vedersi
il perfetto simone uomini de giacomo
grazie mille comunque ragazzi fidatevi
che state per vedere l'epicità sfida
perché io non ho mai giocato a niente
del genere fidatevi se ve lo dico io è
perché non provati i giochi e ho provato
la peggio roba e fidatevi che funzionava
miglia marine rockets e la simil ha
galleggiato bragato la meno male che
meno male perché non solo è quello il
problema
meno male
infilate che è meglio è meglio scoprire
che subito il problema è quello che
facciamo cosi poi riavviare il 38 s
tanto vorrei salvando ritenere se dilaga
un attimo è normale arrivo all right way
the right to write l'ho ripresa lo
ripresa la ripresa che vediamo se adesso
milan gucci ragazzi è già successa la
cosa anche a destra si va beh secondo me
bo riavvio o riavvio il computer raga
tanto non importa la live rimane li
abbiamo solo computer che ha o meno si
dovrebbe ritorno so come mai noi mai suu
kyi mai successo vi giuro
se non rifaccio l'impostazione ci metto
niente yes ragala live funziona uguale
perché grazie a dio tutto sul tuo
computer allora mannaggia uguali
ormai da emilia
allora pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa
vediamo se funziona ok sta pagando ma
tanto dovrei avere realizzato così
facciamo bene questo lo tollero petto
adesso mi ha preso di missili missili
missili mi dimisi perfetto ok
grazie a william adesso se le tele del
sito qualkosa leggo tutti era che strano
boh
che strano che mi ha bloccato ma sai che
se c'è io cambio la porto mannaggia ugas
facciamo prima non so quale sia il
sistema oppure commentato mi metto
questo si vede che se non è un problema
ah ok perché sicuro è un problema del
cacchio è cioè ragazzi a ok fede si no
perché quando come
ci sono ci sono eccolo a posto niente
stavo vedendo qua aspetta un attimo
chissà che cacchio ex ogni volta strano
però non me l'ha mai successo sfiga
tremenda
ok a mandare mi chiami dovrà ripartire
ragazzone in fibrillazione registrato 66
video su sta roba devo partire
assolutamente è più forte di me è troppo
bello sto gioco devo provarlo
assolutamente in live ragazze se non lo
prova in live ho finito di vivere
ok ok
proviamo a vedere se funziona e li
mortacci nia che ciò sembra sfiga ci
sono ragazze non sono scomparso di don
angelo sto tentando limetta questi
settaggi allora vediamo sono fissato
speriamo di sì
beh sì sì ho pensato ci sono ci sono
canzoni ma ci sono ragazzi ho fatto ha
funzionato e funziona peggio a maggio a
spec ha funzionato ora è a monte del cam
link porca trottola monza e la webcam mi
ammazzo san siro da webcam
se non si veda webcam attacco l'altra me
ne sbatto le balle si vedono cribiù
l'attacco la guarda piuttosto attacco
l'altro me ne sbatto le vale ma sai
partiamo presi tre video metto l'altra
webcam me ne sbatto proprio le palle non
me ne frega niente di questo ok ci siamo
ai ragazzi secondo e partiamo al mai
risolto non solo metterla webcam che
sono mi vedete
ok è a posto così
così mi vedete per bene eccoci
ciao a posto sto solo 71 webcam così che
almeno ci siamo perfetto gameplay
è la piazza qua ok ci ha messo sei ore a
sori scusatemi raga sempre i soliti
problemi quando parto
allora proprio grossa sono emozionato
come un bambino di due anni
perché un gioco pazzesco ragazzi è un
gioco pazzesco ve lo dico io ci ho
giocato poca roba così che mi ha preso
così tanto all'inizio poca roba ragazzi
quindi fidatevi di me
fidatevi di me mi sentite bene mi vedete
bene sono bello che grazie ciao
vabbè allora for guys and e rovigo
posiziono per bene che mi mando anche un
dramma catino che sono pigro positivo ci
siamo praga for guys è il momento è il
momento scusate se avuto un piccolo
intoppo ma ogni tanto al mio pc di
girare così non è non che abbia un senso
non saprei descrivere allora adesso
grazie mille william innanzitutto va pm
grazie alle prelazioni collaborazione
anche alessia grazie mille il miglior
testa pinolo welcome it e giacomo lavi
grazie per la nazione e grazie mille per
gli auguri che oggi ragazzi e sun parigi
lo sapete tutti e safari j l'importante
è saperlo si sente non si sente una
colona cremona ritorno ci mette
insegnamenti
meno male alessandro welcome grazie
mille frate grazie mille 6 sul project
il è veramente sono veramente in
fibrillazione sto gioco ragazzi e la
vita fatta videogioco è incredibile
allora tac william te che so much e
grazie mille brother
grazie mille
ok adesso scuole che le cose perché
spero non faccia casino ma non penso
grazie mille ragazzi che si vendono
azioni siete super gentili adesso se
parte
si parte con la storia di sto gioco
pazzesco no ragazzi veramente
ho aspettato una procura perché è uscito
nel 2020 un gioco dell'incredibile se
farsi averlo fatto uscire adesso la
storia si meritava molto molto prima
tosto successo solo che ci hanno messo
una vita a farlo uscire
quindi siamo facciamo qui è la madonna
william grazie grazie mille della
donazione williams iii supergentile no
si blocca raga perché sono io che sto
smanettando per aggiustare cioè adesso
ve lo rivelo giusto ci metto un secondo
scusate un board è un bordello spiegarvi
come come diavolo sto facendo fa ste
robe però è tutto normale tranquilli
allora l'audio in 3 2 1 che per
funzionare e restar l'audio e ricordiamo
ci siamo finalmente i miei ragazzi che
mi vedo giocare su for guys della prima
volta vi ripeto ora che sia un classe
mila ancora william sei un fratello
grazie per il supporto super broffice
allora vi ripeto ora che siete in tanti
innanzitutto ciao
se siete arrivati da questo video lo
lasciò sul canale quindi se siete
arrivati da dove non siete in diretta ma
lo state vedendo più avanti questo e
fall guys e io ci ho già giocato ragazzi
a polgai orgia registrato un video che
vedrete domani domani guardatevi tutti i
video di domani che su fall gaiso video
montato non è una live ovviamente è
quella è stata la mia prima partita for
guys e mi è piaciuto talmente tanto che
ho detto non posso aspettare domani per
farvi vedere il dito lo faccio oggi in
live quindi adesso siamo in live su folk
guys
ma non è la mia prima partita ci ho
giocato appunto domani guardatevi tutti
il video lo stesso è perché merita vauro
come ho detto prima ragazzi allora
l'obiettivo l'obiettivo assoluto visto
gioco è arrivare primi
non in questo mini gioco ma in tutti i
miei giochi perché ci sono cinque mini
giochi 60 partecipanti che sono questi
che vedete 60 partecipanti cinque mini
giochi in questi cinque mini giochi alla
fine vincerà soltanto uno
quindi è tipo fortnight tipo un pattern
royale po più stupido e niente bisogna
arrivare primi il discorso è che non
importa
arrivare primi nel mini giochi basta
arrivare primi alla fine in questo mi
dicevo si classificano i primi 37
ok io sono arrivato adesso stesso senso
quindi buono 6 sposò nel fotogramma
quindi molto buono però non importa se
arrivò sesto o trentasettesimo
chissenefrega tanto l'importante è non
essere eliminati e questo è il primo
mini gioco già la metà della gente fuori
dalle palle
ok ok adesso ci sono ancora quattro i
giochi pian piano deve rimanere soltanto
uno quindi dove vincerli tutti ok tutti
ed è molto molto molto difficile
luigi gas e per la nazione jimmy debito
grazie mio di lavorazione francesco te
che so much
grazie mille per lavorare gas questa è
la prima preso dal primo livello
easy primo è molto easy roll out loud
ragazzi un gioco invece dove dobbiamo
adesso ce la giochiamo tra noi 47
rimasti e 47 erano non ho letto bene
quale se ne eliminano qui vedete quanti
se ne eliminano in alto a destra c'è
scritto sempre su 15 verranno eliminati
15 persone ok io devo resistere
non devo essere tra questi 15 eliminati
va bene ok
tra l'altro è veramente fatto bene e sto
gioco io vi giuro non so se avete mai
visto takeshi custer ragazzi che si
scatena un problema che andava in onda
forse va ancora non da adesso lo so ma
io lo guardavo tantissimo ed è così
c'hai takeshi's cast e lei questo con
gli esseri umani per seguire un
programma vero né fei e io ho sempre
sognato un gioco di takeshi's castle
finalmente uscito finalmente è riuscito
il gioco più bello della storia qua
vengono eliminati in 15 finché non si
eliminano felici persone la partita va
avanti non deve cadere devo rimanere tra
i primi quindici ragazzi molto difficile
devo rimanere tra i primi 15 veramente
un casino ti va mattia giulia grazie per
le nazioni la live ci sarà anche domani
mattina certo che devono inermi che
voglia lo sto facendo io in live adesso
perché non potevo resistere a farvi
aspettare domani perché domani esce il
video di faul geyser ripeto per
l'ennesima volta domani esce non potevo
aspettare di farvi vedere più giovani
perché è troppo bello mi piace troppo e
lo gioco anche per i cazzi miei
e quindi ho detto vabbè lo faccio anche
in live perché è troppo bello si presta
troppo ai video sto gioco è troppo bello
non vi posso prospettato mani domani
guardate 1 lo stesso perché è bello
farvi vedere che qual è stato il mio
primo approccio al suo gioco quindi
guardate le poi da lì ci saranno un
sacco di video però oggi vi faccio
vedere il live come allora ho giocato
già una ventina di parlamentino troppo
una decina di partite quindi so che la
tattica migliore per rollout toni milani
di dosso brutto schifoso l'aido
la tattica migliore di rollout rimanere
ai lati perché i lati c'è meno bordello
teoricamente cioè questo è quello che ho
appurato nel casino per l'ovale e questo
22 reining ogni volta che finisce una
partita mi rileggo le donazioni perché
magari mi son dimenticato qualcosa ai
ragazzi perché siete tanti quindi
rivolta inficia partita si diventi come
cosa rileggo don't worry se volete
ragazzi abbonarvi hackerare il tasto è
qua sotto
grazie mille leonardo club per la
donazione tipo lui mi è sembrato in java
avete anche i vari perché vedete nella
borazione qua sotto dico abbo nazioni
apposta e non è una presa per il culo
cioè non è che sto subendo io le
donazioni invece se volete supportarli
con superski su perfetto o qui supersic
casa con fregati questo raga io lo odio
allora c'è una strada giusta che non
vediamo va culo quello ha avuto un culo
finale ok ok ok che ti prendevi di
questo si no a scriverlo arrivato primo
aiuto
bisogna scoprire la strada giusta
arrivare fino alla fine ma è
difficilissimo ma di un difficile che
non avete idea allora qua bisogna
saltare qualcuno scopra qualcosa
qualcuno bravo dai 61 aiuto ditemi che
non ci arrivano vi prego no non ci
arriva mai lucerino mai cadete strozzi
per oggi ma già fatti ma ce l'ha fatta
minuti ma non solo
minchia grazie mille all'ora ragazzi per
leonardo che la donazione william però
donazione sono arrivato per ultimo
piccolo che cumulo totale ma donna
bellissima sta roba è veramente bello
perché è bello perché ti dà una
soddisfazione incredibile cesa è l'unico
questo l'unico batteria che posso
vincere lo so rafael takedown nation my
brother grazie mille allora ragazzi
questo è folgor tipo rocket league con
due palle passatemi il termine due palle
bisogna portare la palla
la porta avversaria e the a team quindi
ci dividiamo a metà di noi verrà
eliminata il problema di faul ball
ve lo dico subito e che si gioca sempre
in dispari c'e quindi una squadra a meno
gente che in questo caso la mia
[ __ ] che non vale cioè nel senso
secondo me dobbiamo giocarla tutti
quanti e dove ha messo lo stesso numero
di persone
se siamo dispari perché fai le squadre
da due e bisogna la metà viene eliminata
qua quindi all i gialli vengono promossi
o il blu gli altri vengono tutti
eliminati quindi se perdiamo noi gialli
abbiamo perso buttare la palla dentro
ma dico ha buttata da dire a qualcuno
importa c'è qualcuno importa uno solo in
porta porco demonio ragazzi non posso
fare cristiano ronaldo qualcuno sia
importa e qualcuno attacchi
mannaggia il cariolo tu che sei davanti
segna no devi stare ma qualcuno che
porta da noi chi c'è in porta nessuno
siete pazzi bene gol che permette 10 ma
domanda che ci passa sotto il mio
personaggio alla ragazzi parate o addio
di orly c'e la palla odio ragazzi amo
troppo poco importa secondo me troppo
poco importa troppo pochi importa devi
passare avanti a palla la palla avanti
bravo chi è che ti è stata cristiano
ronaldo perfetto perfetto finale ai
mondiali
fabio grosso da buttar avanti e
motorette bravissimo siamo 30 al cic
resto siamo in minoranza e va ben ammar
e b questo è impossibile
questo è possibile aiuto questo è
possibile
come faccio non si può fare la palla sta
qua
occhio che la rimonta in attimo ai
ragazzi 56 secondi succede di tutto ok
la parola rezgui magari vale di più non
fatelo entrare entrata meno male che
voleva solo uno no parate madonna la che
ha scarsi ma i nostri in attacco che
cacchio stanno facendo 2 a 2
fate qualcosa in attacco
mannaggia cacchio io in difesa 22 raga
siamo in minoranza manca uno no che tiro
toglietevi faccio io
togliete aiuto ho tirato incredibile
ragazzi parate siete tutti dietro vado
in attacco ci penso io
chi testata andrea pirlo proprio lui a
dai qualcosa ma fate cambiano ragazzi ma
dai ma chi è che ha fatto prendere gol
fatto bravi tra tre c'è una possibilità
sufficiente a farla se vi siete a
parlare rugby
stringete la dai che si va ai
supplementari qua siamo uno in meno è
comunque tutto sto casino un in meno
spingi spingi da balla a iniziare
l'altra palla spero che non sia nella
nota lettura già il cazzo davano tutti
in difesa tutti io in attacco io che
attacco e abbiamo preso gol cosa
facevate in difesa giocavate a carte
cosa facevate indipen i compagni stupidi
maledetti non me lo meritavo
ho giocato da dio lo stato bravissimo
andate a cagare tutti
morì te ma scherzi morite nel gioco
comunque ragazzi e cioè non è possibile
voglio voglio morire cioè non è
possibile ragazzi che non lo meritavo
non vale 9 da questa è la buona
peccato è veramente un peccato che potrà
andare molto meglio nome non cacchio di
guardare gli altri da uscire non me lo
meritavo nome secondo me si può
secondo me poteva potevo vincere io
comunque spero che questa pensa prima
partita vi sia piaciuta secondo me
potevamo fare molto meglio ma faremo
meglio adesso del gol
comunque io non so veramente che cosa
dire perché comunque sto gioco è
pazzesco
ve lo giuro io non ho mai giocato niente
del genere ripeti sto ripetendo lo so
mai veramente ci credo in quello che sto
dicendo cioè non è uno sponsor è
veramente figo
mi sono divertito come non mai mi fa in
casa russa con la gente che mi che mi fa
perdere però va bene sempre
riproviamoci secondo me possiamo fare di
meglio io posso vincerla l'ho già ho già
vinto in realtà due volte solo che non
ho vinto perché giocavo per i gatti i
miei vi ripeto ragazzi troppo bello
soggiorno quindi io credo fortemente che
giocare per imperi kaki nostri quando
quando noi youtuber giochiamo una roba
per i cacchi i nostri vuol dire che è
proprio bella cioè non la facciamo solo
per tipo io happy with non la gioco per
il kindle o gioco briga fine del gioco
da piccolo per capire questo qua lo sto
giocando adesso è veramente bello ti
puoi andare giù porca [ __ ] grazie io
stavo davanti all'unica porta non andava
giù perfetto sono troppi aiuto al timimi
che ci entro sono entrato si fa bene a
posto la posta fosse a posto come ci sia
buona ragazzi se volete abbonarmi al
canale tasto abbonati e qua sotto
se volete schiacciare abbonati serve per
supportarmi avete anche un sacco di
perche di polito in anteprima cosa è
molto carina li vedete qua sotto avete
anche i canali di scolo che abbiamo
appena aperto tutto molto figo jonathan
che canali di scolo ragazzi seconda
invece supportati con la donation magari
farmi la domanda
potete fare la donazione come super chat
o con i super sticker che ci sono sempre
nella super chat molto molto molto molto
grande e il ringraziamento da parte mia
se lo fate grazie mila ragazzi per il
supporto
questo gioco è pazzesco e vi ripeto
domani esce il video su col guy
non perdetevelo perché è unico dolce fra
influito allora questa è la perdo sempre
spero di vincerla ma questa io di basell
ha aperto sempre faccio pagare perché
non a parte che si classificano in 19
quindi è veramente pochissimi di quelli
che sta giocando si classificheranno e
non sono buono schivare la frutta perché
qua devi arrivare alla fine devi
scrivere la frutta che cade il problema
è che william
grazie mille per il super sticker mega
questo super sic e ragazzi dovevo farlo
ciao grazie vibrazioni grazie mille
miglia per il supporto di oggi e grazie
mille frate ce la faccio
oddio dio secondo ragazzi io faccio
pagare il terzo faccio cagare di solito
a questo ve lo giuro ho fatto una
provata in genere in questo faccio
pagare a spruzzo sono stato bravissimo
vi giuro incredibile francesco
evangelista che si predazione fra i live
di minecraft o anche live allora
minecraft non lo farò il live perché non
credo sia un gioco live
ma questo lo è faccio tanti altri giochi
live ragazzi minecraft non è tanto da
live
dati che centro un po la webcam che vedo
che un po storta ok perfetto la scalata
anche in pieno per tutti qua mi metterò
più alto il giocatore frega ci siamo
ragazzi dei sì allora questo è a tim
anche questo team siamo in 19 quindi
siamo in pochi
due team anche qua comunque se siamo
hingis pari io non mi metterei mai in
livelli a tim
però va bè fa niente bisogna centrare il
maggior numero di cerchi la squadra che
centrano cielo per i cerchi mica siamo
in tre team che noi siamo in blu
burroughs allora 1 e ce l'abbiamo
bisogna centrale maggior numero ricerche
è difficilissimo ve lo assicuro perché
avessi già li sta perdendo
adesso spuntano dice archivi prevedere
dove spuntano meno male che sono
abbastanza skillato no porca [ __ ] di ok
che ce l'ho ancora sono ancora
tranquillo trovino alcuni valgono alcuni
valgono di più era provava siamo
bravissimi 11 punti
alcuni genti valgono di più e valgono
tipo tantissimo valgono tipo 5
questo vale uno ad esempio ok quello sta
labbra io vedo solo blu che si buttano
come cacchio è possibile che siamo pari
con i gialli vedo solo in più che si
buttano come possibile la non c'e
nessuno raga la ci sono solo rossi
maledizione qualcuno di qua madonna che
ansia perché poi mette una sin credibile
perché può essere limitato da un secondo
all'altro ok
spero che questo 9 da nessuno no però
potuto alla fine siamo pari aiuto perché
l'ho preso 27 59 secondi sono tantissimi
ragano anche ancora troppo tempo ok una
persona fa la differenza è veramente
vivo ok 30 i rossi sono 27 ott
io che gran casino dai bravo un queste
cello l'ho preso io l'ho preso il mero
dato
ma come non l'ho preso ma non ho preso
brava tato spero me l'ha dato l'ho preso
tantissimo rappresentato tantissimo
adesso vi rispondo ai ragazzi un attimo
preso vi dico le donazioni rispondo per
bene per tutte quando finisce la gara
perché sennò divento pazzo a leggere
tutto 45 36 forzano persi rossi ma
ancora andamenti secondi sono tantissimi
gira gira gira gira gira gira fortissimo
di reagire gira gira togliti dai palle
su giallo
l'ho preso io sono forte togliti al
cazzo ma dai è come 54 noi ragazzi
dovremmo avercela fatta perfetto come
poi siamo forti sono stato bravissimo
grazie a tutti
ok cecchini alexa simile fa i condoni
andrea aquafan spero molto presto carlos
pena molto meno se mi sono molto
divertito
ciao vicini ai primi 12 o guerra che
comunque ho fatto due partite e due
partite sono arrivati quasi in finale
non è male fidatevi è difficile partiamo
in 60 eri quindi vuol dire che sono
nella top ten top 12 da tappeto
va beh almeno siamo il team è bilanciato
siamo in sei contro sei ok non mi fa
incazzare
non mi fanno incazzare che poi andate
tutti quanti a morire nella classifica
quindi non meno vi fate incacchiare
giochiamo bene via qualcuno stia in
porta per l'amor di dio se non vado io
piuttosto non è un problema basta che
qualcuno stia dietro e gli altri davanti
siamo in tre davanti quindi ci sono tre
dietro ci sono tre dietro quindi
dobbiamo paranà palla dietro bravo 10
spingete fingete occhio occhio li occhio
che nessuno e cade un'altra occhio che a
parare il wii che cade ok bravissimi
bravi sismici questo perfetto occhio non
perfetto un cacchio spinta malissimo
specie della palla davanti noi stiamo
dietro dipende però a volte alla
calciata così bravi sio cristiano
ronaldo
comunque non so perchè ci faccio sempre
sotto la palla non so come mai
oppure mi tuffo bene
dai che ne mancano 12 siamo 1 a 0 un
minuto comunque stata l'acqua dovrebbe
valere di più secondo messo là dentro
perché c'è proprio difficile da colpire
la palla del 2 0 dai spingete spinge
dobbiamo schiacciarli 2 a 0 non è per
niente un risultato rassicurante 2 a 0
si perde anche qui abbiamo perso da zero
ok ok ok no mica è svenuto un in mezzo è
svenuto visto svenire aiuta ancora via
insomma da solo ma chi c'è c'è che viene
votare solo la palla che rotola qua
vado avanti io mi chiama raga ma
veramente c'è un contatto
no no no ragazzo che sbattute in faccia
occhio no mica chi e come fanno a tirare
così forte mi chiedo andare dietro c'è
paura
togliti ma cosa fai togliti è lì che poi
io stupido 3 a 2 e meno male abbiamo
segnato anche noi
meno male io rimango dietro state avanti
stata avanti state avanti per l'amore di
gesù bravissimo fa vj che tiro che tiro
che tiro nel favi che ero da cui
tuffarsi non serve a niente
cioè serve agli altri a meno perché a me
non spinge a vallà buttandovi ok ok
guardo segnato faccio segnato gaga
contro ad una infezione 30 secondi
questa è buona cosa buona
buttatevi la pole a rugby buttatevi
quello no così aiuto se latenti passate
nell'acqua ragazzi basta tenerlo qua
anche se non avanza va bene buono mono
52 52 fosse fatta forse fatta con 75 2
punta che questo aiuto sole fermo con le
fermo forse fa attacco forse è fatta
buttate là dentro
buttate dentro qualcuno va bene ci
questo riso ce la fa annunciavamo
ci abbiamo fatto ho fatto anche un gol
buono buono luca al 2008 e non sembra
l'azione come si fa a scaricare questo
gioco lo trovi su steam fratello oppure
lo trovi su playstation store gratis se
il processo il naso o addirittura qui li
deve essere gratis su steam costa 12
notti 19 tutti gli altri morti rimaniamo
in sei ragazzi bellissimo bellissimo
finale finale siamo in finale
ok questa è la royal fumble praticamente
come funziona devi rimanere l'ultimo con
la coda nel culo
c'è una coda che tutti prendete la metti
nel deretano e gli altri leoni seguirti
e prendertela ok non ce l'ho io
bisogna prendere questa cosa e rimanere
per ultimo quindi puoi anche non averla
tutto il tempo ma averla per ultimo e va
bene l'ultimo secondo e va bene hai
vinto basta basta solo questo il
problema grosso
ecco adesso ce l'ho io eh ma tanto non
importa perché devi avercela per ultimo
sono non vale niente ce l'ho io porca
vacca
ok resisto non resistere un minuto e
mezzo ha vinto con ce la farò mai è
tantissimo minuto e mezzo la capitale è
veramente tab vale tanto vale che
aspettiamo alla fine e poi che si crei
losone finale e proviamo a rubarci alla
vicenda perché è proprio difficile
affidateli eccolo qua no sono svenuto un
minuto non ce la fa a resistere frate mi
dispiace può tornare indietro aiuto lo
dirò break no già preso lui aiuto io che
casino mi dico ma l'ho preso io
ma la rigida tasse colombaio del
novecento detto che cacchio
e vabbè è troppa ginesi e va bene
troppa gente se invece vi 6 non è anche
da anche tanti penso che che anzi se
fosse quindi più una delle due volte che
ho vinto l'ho vinta quasi ci ho preso
alla fine alla coda è riuscita a tenerla
è un casino ragazzina dove cacchio è lo
pensa non c'era quello 30 secondi quello
ce l'ha avuta fin troppo comunque due
ora che ce l'ha che palle
allora mi conviene rimanere nel mezzo no
madonna sta facendo casino lingue 20
secondi e secondi c'è il casinò c'è
casino 17 ok se uno di noi sono caduto
10 secondi non ci credo dimmi che ci
arrivo di michael i motivi che ci arrivo
dove sta la 5 43 aiuto 21
no no già avevamo peccato ci sta ai
ragazzi finale impossibile il finale
veramente difficile è libera è la più
difficile binario vinci sta il suo
fortissimo buono ma si formano demi para
son grazie frate grazie mille buon
onomastico a tutti lorenzi d'italia e
del mondo
la malesia anche jorge lorenzo qual è il
disco ragazzi nel post community se
andate sulla scheda community di file e
tv trovate il link di disco per
connettermi ci sono anche le varie
stanze
enjoy e molto divertente perché possiamo
parlare insieme molto figo ragazzi se
volete supportarmi ragazzi con le
donazioni usate la super chat po di
bianco oppure con le con gli abbonamenti
qua sotto 100 fa bona chi eventi vari
perche scelte perché l'abbonamento io vi
saluto in live se mi compare appunto
perché mi compare l'aler condotto donate
o di abbonati con qualsiasi nozione
grazie mille ragazzi comunque per il
supporto è andata bene
vincere è proprio vabbè il top si spera
però arrivare in finale età è come una
vittoria perché arrivare in finale
comunque arrivi tra i primi sei e
partiamo in 60 qui non è male
certo che vincere non è non sarebbe non
sarebbe malaccio
io ve lo dico ragazzi sul canale
usciranno due video settimanali di faul
guys di questo gioco qua due video
settimanali tutte le settimane a partire
da questa settimana con questa live 3
perché questa cosa faceva mandare due
video avremo tre video settimanali di
polgai su un gioco spettacolare questo
qua ragazzi
domani ci sarà il primo video normale di
for guys con i vari tagli quindi un
video normale sarà è la mia prima volta
su fa guys quindi farà ridere per voi
perché non saprò giocarci perché è lì la
prima volta che ci gioco adesso sono già
un po più bravino però guardatelo perché
fa morire e poi dal prossimo episodio
c'è da da quello dopo ancora
sono fischi nato ma con i giovani non
perdete lo chiede grafiche carino non
perderlo perché ci sarà due volte alla
settimana e ragazze due volte la
settimana e spettacolare non perdetelo
perché il gioco incredibile regalo
ragazzi con questa nuova manche di for
guys
partiamo subito e civico quasi sempre a
prima volta è raro che io venga
eliminato subito quindi ok non sono mai
preoccupato con la prima mi concentro di
più sulle ultime perché sono più
difficili credo di averle provate quasi
tutte le modalità gioca con mike welcome
in the pancrazio grazie mille per
l'abbonamento massimo frate grazie mille
favi fai più race game frate questo è un
range game fidati ogni tanto io qua mi
sto tenendo tanto è cena un insulto
neanche gli avversari tiro solo pugni
alla tastiera fortissimo ma vi assicuro
che quando gioco per i cacchi miei il
calendario viene ripassato quindi non vi
preoccupate questo è un regime vi vedete
mi vedrete rage aree parecchio giusto
un incrocio tra super meat boy a livello
di ray cechet mario state tranquilli io
mi sto tenendo molto team termine taylor
a questo è come quello di prima quindi
questo bisogna rubare la coda però è
hakim e viene eliminato un team ci sono
quattro team quindi questo c'è la coda
tra l'altro e ce ne sono tante quindi il
team che alla fine alla fine del tempo
ha più code vince ok ci sono un totale
di dodici corde io né una bisogna
semplicemente rimanere il team con più
comode sto strambo e prova a prendermi
una tattica buona ragazzi rimanere tipo
ecco non questa è rimanere qua sotto
quando siete abbastanza soli perchè la
gente per beccarvi deve passare sopra
questo lo sviluppatesi tattica perché ci
ho giocato almeno già tre o quattro
retta suo gioco da solo
pensate ma tocca kim ha preso siamo qua
perfetto siamo qua uno che ha la coda
non può rubarvi la coda ok quindi è la
tattica giusta bravo frate rimanere qua
sotto finché qualcuno non vi attacca
tipo questo allora poi ci muoviamo
perché sennò poi ci prende però è
passare vicino agli ostacoli la tattica
giusta questo sta fermo devi muoverti
frate solo ti pigliano ok così un minuto
ho tenuto sempre la mia coda niente male
appena finisco vi leggo e ragazzi arriva
il blu rivaldo lario all'occhio no come
ma quanto ci metti a rialzarmi cazzo
sono caduto per primo sono caduto per il
primo dei due è mio cervello mi sono
alzato per l'ultimo quanto ci metto
rialzarmi che problemi che cacchio a
coltivare così non prenderò mai la coda
avrei perfetto il solo presa con 5 circa
e beni che lui avrebbe subito la cosa
come possibile conoscenze su due ore ad
alzarmi prima ma com'è possibile
prendi a cosa l'ho presa 34 secondi cam
onlus che sfiga
togliti blu hanno questo c'e l'accordo
che preferito rimane un quali ma di un
po rimaniamo fuori mandiamo quali
mandiamo cacchio
ma dai ok non mi ha colpito aiuto c'è
grosso e vabbè o che culo torri
il blu ne hanno 7 cioè come è possibile
dieci secondi raga non perdete la coda
in ghiaia di gialli non prende la coda
non perdetela 4 3 2 1 4 pari tutti ok
non hanno perso alla fine qualcuno ha
rubato una coda che meno male erano
quattro fari all'ultimo secondo
tale granata irene grazie per donazioni
grazie mille ora leggo anche cosa è
descritto 37 remaining passiamo a 28
quindi già dimezzati a partire
dall'inizio di alimentati normale
mamma mia ragazzi sto prendendo troppo
bene visto gioco fidatevi è da ieri che
ci gioco tutti i giorni veramente figo
spero il dio di vincere una partita in
live sarebbe bellissimo è difficilissimo
vincere una partita perché arrivati alla
fine ha prima eravamo in sei di base
alla fine non ci arrivi in 6 12 10
quindi già prima era era una buona
possibilità una su sei e poi non è molto
meritocratico alla fine va nuova cumulo
di pene gomiti gira poi certo ci sono le
tattiche però allora questa è la
banalità che ho fatto solo una volta non
cadere giù
semplicemente non devi cadere questa
fare gira ragazzi perché ma qualcuno di
voi domanda l'aveva mai visto takeshi's
castel perché veramente figo takeshi's
castle games fatto con le persone e
bellissimo sono avete mai visto tavolo
sono cadendo sotto non avete mai visto
takeshi's castel guardatelo allora
questa non è a tempo
cosa vuol dire vuol dire che vengono
eliminati i primi dodici i primi 12 che
che cadono ben due eliminati e poi
finisce la partita finché non cadono 12
persone non finisce
ok questi sono i livelli un po più
bastati che vi aspettavate dura un sacco
perché non di suo con aliminare la gente
come ho fatto a sopravvivere lo so solo
io e molto difficile strappare ragazzi
figuriamoci se riesco a farlo con
tranquillità perché vi mettono ansia ste
cose che mancano 4 è 4 abbiamo fatto 10
dai ancora due ancora due per terra però
uno ce l'ho fatta sono fatta perfetto
alessandro thank you so much for the
damnation irene buon compleanno
non avevo letto grazie mille la
donazione buon compleanno è difficile
l'intera gamma ce la fa ce la faremo
melo promesso 16 quale file non so se in
questa ma ve lo prometto ce la faremo
modifica il personaggio biso lo farò
quando avrò abbastanza nome da sbloccare
perché qua comunque ragazzi non vi ho
fatto vedere ma anche personalizzabile
per cambiarti metodi costumi vedete che
gli altri hanno i costumi strani molto
figo faccio puoi vedere le per varie
personalizzazioni facciamo una micro
pausa rock and roll
allora questa è difficile ma c'è una
tattica che vi faccio vedere a bisogna
semplicemente portare la palla palla al
traguardo per primi non scusatemi non
bisogna arrivare ultimi gli ultimi
vengono eliminati quindi i primi due che
la portano sono promossi ci vengono
passano turno è difficile perché perché
adesso succederà una cosa che vedrete
tutti quanti vedete che uno è già andato
avanti nei miei questo perché perché non
è tanto essere veloci quanto essere
furbi e bravi alla fine perché alla fine
succede una cosa particolare che adesso
vedrete
ragazzi siete scarsi come la morte ok ci
eravamo impantanati ma ce l'abbiamo
fatta
adesso succede una cosa stai blu sono
arrivati buttate giù adesso l'obiettivo
non è tanto arrivare alla fine quanto
bloccare la palla degli altri
bisogna bloccare la palla degli altri
quindi noi siamo qua che la blocchiamo e
questi sono qua che la spingono quindi
se noi riuscissimo a arrivare alla fine
perché i gialli stanno bloccando la
nostra e noi stiamo bloccando quella dei
gialli giustamente quindi l'obiettivo è
fermare la palla degli altri è molto
difficile loro ok spingente la palla
fili dalla nostra rossa perfetto
perfetto perfetto perfetto perfetto i
gialli devono rimanere su i gialli non
rimane su fermi gialli fermi
completamente bravi bravissimi gisa
schmidt e giacomo supersoldato dei più
forte donation grazie mille ragazzi la
sto tenendo i rozzi dove siete siete
ancora lì
che saggiamente temibile e muoiono
ragazzi gli ultimi gli ultimi vanno a
morire perché li elimina completamente
quindi i gialli o rossi non mi è mai
successo di arrivare prima di godermela
bravi bravi spingete vigente adesso
bravi io la tengo ancora equa bravissimi
bravi ragazzi abbiamo fatto la gara
allora meno quanti sono cinque meno 5
arriviamo a 11 forse c'è la finale
adesso non mi ricordo quanti eravamo
dieci le mailing dieci romeni in vado a
morire tutti quanti arrivano in finale
quindi 5 blu e 5 rossi che va beh siamo
tutti contro tutti con te finale credo
sia il finale perché ci sono cinque gare
in totale non lo so se il finale spero
di sì
final round questo non l'ho mai fatto
laga questo non l'ho mai fatto paura non
l'ho mai fatto questo devi rimanere
l'ultimo sulla pedana ma non l'ho mai
fatto vi giuro devi rimanere l'ultimo
ultimo in piedi senza cadere alla fine
ecco già partiamo male è difficilissimo
quanto pare prima negli ultimi il
problema è che non avendolo mai fatto
non so le tattiche dagli altri più o
meno società non sono andò malissimo
secondo me non sto andando proprio
malissimo non è male no no no no no no
no no la donna sono canturino livelli ok
non so le tattiche raga non le so devo
rimanere al bordeaux teoricamente poi
adesso cadono tutti che è molto
difficile problema secondo me mi
conviene guardare sotto dove non ci sono
buchi perché quello che fa ok mi sono
buttato mi sono portato anche qui
perfetto passo da dietro bravissimo
vigia intenzione che tattica bravo
mi chiami sotto quando l'ho preso non ci
credo le donne sono fenomeno i lati due
ne mancano sette macro 7 numero 7 che
bravo che sono stato sono l'unico nel
blu non è vero c'è pure un altro che è
caduta adesso però oddio oddio dio dio
dio no nel mio ora ne mancano quattro
sono i finalissima altre ne mancano tre
sono nel viola che gli altri cacchio no
no no arrivati il mega finale ne
mancavano due ne mancavano due ne
mancano due ruoli raga era tanto così
porcava prodotto così no e non lo sapevo
madonna questi stanno resistendo ancora
qualche roba ha vinto l'altro madonna
ragazzo così no beh dai però però non
avevo mai o non l'avevo mai fatta giuro
questa è la prima volta per non averla
mai fatta ho tanta roba
non l'avevo mai fatta secondo me non è
male poteva andare molto peggio perché
poi ti dà un sacco di punti in base a
quanto arrivi è ovviamente essendo
arrivato terzo nato un sacco di punti
se arrivi primo se arrivi primissimo ti
da questo ti dà questo che la corona la
corona con le corone ti puoi comprare le
cose adesso vi faccio vedere
nella utility facciamo un'altra partita
ok ho perso ma non non non è ma non sono
arrabbiato perché non era male perché
non sono andato vale per niente era di
film non l'avevo mai fatta non avendola
mai fatta non sapendo le tattiche sono
auto iii c he cacchio dai non è male
secondo me sto gioco solo una promessa e
ci gioco ancora un po e secondo me
diventi incredibile se ne facciamo
subito un'altra che hanno in faccia
vedere chi comanda prima che finisca
live de vinco una quanto è vero iddio
allora cosa come funziona questi sono
gli outfit non è un po una volta ho
vinto e mi ha dato questo che però non
so se me l'ha dato per la vittoria per i
livelli di faccia c'è solo questa ce ne
sono anche altre ovviamente o questo qua
che aveva il vincitore di prima ma non
mi piace non lo metto nelle parti di
sotto invece ho questo e questo questo
ma mi piace non so perché non avevo
ancora messo la metto i colori che io
tengo saranno spero sempre questi po
come visto che sto gioco diventerà un po
un icona del mio canale ragazzi
diventerà un'icona è troppo bello
quindi io terrò questi colori quasi
sempre proprio perché voglio trovare una
caratteristica che di
[Musica]
mi assegni mica mi accompagni in tutto
questo percorso e terrò sempre questi
cori qua arancione e blu che sono
comunque i colori adesso non so niente
mi fa vedere sono i colori di base del
mio canale anche se e multicolor logo
però di base erano arancione blu e
azzurro quindi terrò questi due queste
le cose che puoi trovare poi anche
cambiare le esultanze che sono queste
qua che però non l'ho mai fatto perché
non è che mi interessano particolarmente
e man mano che sale di livello ti
sblocchi queste cose se non ce lo shop
dove poi sbloccarti robe comprati roba o
con le corone che io ho oppure con i con
una corona in più riprendo il tempo che
è bellissimo
vorrei vincere la partita per per
prendermi la corona per comprarmi il
centro che è bellissimo però non ho
ancora vinto
oggi quindi niente
arriviamo alla prossima vittoria questa
è la personalizzazione altra roba molto
interessante nella versione playstation
potete avere il nome perso il vostro
nome
mi prendevo nickname nella versione pc
non c'è dic nei mista cosa non ho capito
perché mi che ci chiamiamo tutti i fall
guy con un numero io mi chiamo fall guy
1082 non so perché i ragazzi non ci sono
i nickname su steam strana sta roba
però su playstation sibaud va beh grazie
chiara per la donazione grazie per l per
loro massico vele morire l'onomastico se
molto gentile e
orbene per esempio anch'io ecco insomma
grazie fabio per la donna però ragazzi
fratello perché la gente metteva le
parole ci hanno tolto i nickname
beh però è strano perché comunque la
maggior parte anche rocket league poi
personalizzati nickname
anche solo che click puoi farlo e lì non
l'hanno tolto chi se ne frega non è che
me ne frega niente di vedere in trend
però era non capivo il perché ci sta
comunque questo è un gioco family
friendly magari può starci il fatto che
abbiano tutti nickname però nella
versione playstation no perché la belli
sono ovviamente già tutelati da
playstation primavera si parte
chiacchieriamo laga nella prima parte
perché la prima parte c'è o quando esso
facciamo figura di mer della perla nella
prima parte loro non son è pazzesco e la
roba e non lo so se contro ad uno dei
one direction quando si sono riuniti è
roba incredibile troppa gente quindi
teoricamente a meno che non sei stupido
la prima parte la vinci perché proprio
troppo agrave abbastanza se poi come ho
detto sta cagata e come minimo perdo
però la prima partner
vorrei farvi vedere di partenza un altro
gioco che è il mio preferito che è
quello dove praticamente ti mettono
delle porte e tu devi sfondare con la
testa alcune sono vere alcune sono field
va culo ed è molto molto bello e del
genere il primo gioco per ora non ancora
fatto fatto questo non va bene qua
bisogna stare attenti ragazzi saltate
sempre perché qua c'è un buco se non
saltate cadete subito è di fare sfondare
non vi elimina in automatico se cadete
nella prima di eliminati far restaurare
per gli arrivò sempre tra i primi cinque
comunque nella prima sono molto bravo
con un ometto gioco per un peccato che
comunque il finale molto selettivo
perché alla fine ti mette contro uno
contro dieci più o meno quindi è molto
difficile ma anche molto bello takeshi's
castle sim si ragazzi e takeshi's cast
severamente e wipeout qualcuna mai visto
wipeout è un mix tratta che si scassa e
wipeout bellissima
è veramente bello è il gioco che
sostituirà è più no non credo sostituirà
ex ragazzi perché non l'ho messo la
domenica l'ho messo per adesso il
martedì e il giovedì quindi tutti i
martedì e tutti i giovedì scusatemi il
lunedì a giovedì tutti i lunedì e tutti
i giovedì
vedrete fall guys siccome oggi l'ho
fatto in live e lo faccio uscire domani
come video e poi giovedì però di base ci
sarà lunedì e giovedì sono fall guys
farò solo parti supercar i ragazzi e
bellissimo se lo allora ci sono tanti
mini giochi per adesso non annoia mai e
proprio bello non ti annoi è quello il
bello tra mesi tra qualche mese ci sta
che a furia di giocarci ti vada a noia
perché comunque ci sono sempre le stesse
cose
per quanto non annoia mai perché ogni
partita essendo come fort night ogni
partita essendo tanti giocatori si
sviluppa in modo diverso con i non tipo
mai annoiare totalmente ma se per
ovviare anche a questo metteranno sempre
nuovi minigiochi cosa che credo
fortemente faranno non annoierà mai
ragazzi sto gioco è un gioco
potenzialmente più infinito di happy
meals c'è veramente potrà durare negli
anni sto gioco dieci anni secondo me se
continuano ad aggiornarlo noi non ti
annoia mai
mike è totale e un gioco fina che cazzo
è successo è partito uno nella
stratosfera laga avete visto se fosse
stato un video grezzo amato non posso
zoomare perché siamo in live però è
partito un tipo nella stratosfera porco
demonio e belli stai fermo con le mani
brutto pezzente schifoso l'aido giuste
mani che schifo mollami maledetta la
gente ok 9 su sedici ragazzi
mancano ancora porca vacca 7 eliminati
sono ancora tanti sei adesso quindi devo
tenere erbe questa ragazzi copiate le
mie tattiche perché io abbiamo sempre in
finale mi ritengo abbastanza bravo
copiate quello che faccio in questa roba
rimanete sempre e solo al lato perché a
lato c'è meno gente e potete sbirciare
facilmente dalla corsia prima la corsia
dopo come sto facendo io
vedrete che nel frattempo l'agente
diminuisce secondo me questa è la
miglior tattica ragazzi di manette a
lato e fate così semplice switch perché
nel frattempo la gente si elimina da
sola perché vedete che molta gente
stupida rimane in mezzo sono stupidi
perché in mezzo è più difficile perché
ti devi inneggiare con un sarebbe molto
più confusionario in manetta lato
ragazzi guardate come sopravvivere più
easy ho mancato faccia fiori per lo so
io lo so che faccio come mio però
teoricamente la tattica che mi ha sempre
aiutato arrivare in finale
alberto ciccarelli vuoi convinta e
giacomo my brother grazie mille grazie
per il supporto quanti siamo quale 20
qua ma già detti 4 quindi a noi ma
scusatemi
e lui fa già il calcolo di quelli che
sono caduti nel mentre in più gli ultimi
due li tokyo che lui fa aveva già fatto
il calcolo che pensavo che eliminasse
altri 12 ok grazie fabio per la
donazione grazie mille per la bella
frase mi ha scritto continuerò così i
ragazzi guardatevi tutti i video di for
guys che usciranno da adesso in avanti
usciranno un sacco di video di tolè
fosse amici fa vigeva fall guys due
volte alla settimana a partire da domani
guardate quello di domani è un po meno
esperto di questo ma perché era la mia
prima partita ma è molto divertente
vedere come giocavo ieri alla fine
quella registrata ieri
quindi non è che è passato intanto però
da ieri a oggi ho giocato quattro ore
quindi ho sfilato molto di più le mie
capacità
e quindi sono diventato molto più
bravino adesso però comunque rimane
difficile se ripeto se loggio madonna
schivato a lui se lo aggiornano diventa
potenzialmente infinito ragazzi sto
gioco è bellissimo primo raga io vi
giuro come vi ho detto prima che in st
modalità di voi mi eliminano cioè si
qualificano i primi 13 e in questa
modalità di solito mi eliminano quindi
io non arrivo neanche tra i primi 13 il
live sto arrivando primo e culo perché
vi giuro che sono sempre ultimo la la
tattica per questo che sta funzionando a
quanto vedo segnatevela e rimanere a
lato c'è perché nel mezzo c'è un tronco
che ogni tanto partiti se ti becca è
finito e perso perché arrivi e poi gli
spioni rispondi dall'inizio quindi non
vinci più
rimanete a lato e tentati di schivare
tutte le frutterà tutta la frutta in
mezzo
no perché arriva un pronto ed è e di
spazza via di questo gioco ragazzi e
incredibile spero veramente che vi
piaccia guardatevi ve lo ripeto per
l'ennesima volta varate vivido che
usciranno perché sono pazzeschi
non solo nei gialli di vigano sono i
gialli che sono in meno mica non sono i
gialli che sono di meno bisogno di
plurimi che sono i blu di me che sono i
due se siamo uno in più questa roba qua
non ha senso ragazzi non vale secondo me
mettere una squada in minoranza poi
magari vincono anche lei prima abbiamo
vinti minoranza però un gioco anche nel
calcio quando si gioca 10 contro 11 la
con la squadra in dieci è nettamente
svantaggio perché un giocatore fa la
differenza figuriamoci 7 contro 6
perché questa modalità la fanno partire
quando siamo in dispari è sbagliato è
totalmente sbagliato però vabbè
chissenefrega
andiamo avanti vaia e spingete io tengo
questa spingete davanti ai siti in due
contro due spingete siete in due contro
due
spinge no chi è importa ragazzi dai fate
qualcosa che scarsi
va bene non è ancora detto niente
nicchia e che cazzo sei maradona un tiro
da metà campo cos'è a finale in terra
argentina bravo la mano de dios
cristiano ronaldo che do alla rete e
mezzo e mezzo fila di champions
porca vacca che grave mi metto questa
questa è la modalità tra tutte che mi
mette più enfasi
perché ansiolitica al massimo e
ansiolitica come non mai aiuto quella
tirato bravo zio claudio raitre via
bravissimo va bene va bene va bene 11
ragazzo non in meno vi ripeto e uno in
meno quindi questa va vinta è questa non
va persa va vinta se non giocate di
merda bravi bravi bravi spingente sono
due palle due palle lì io rimango nel
mezzo che appena dio a quella nuova la
stringo subito dentro se riesco
rimango nel mezzo se arriva con la nuova
aspetta che ok allora scrivo questa fa
più avanti
ok non sono riuscito a vo ragazzi
spingete nel mezzo
spingete nel mezzo spinge teschi cetera
in mezzo bravi ma da aveva becco
successo lì è che lo è successo la palla
cosa dov'è andata cos'è se pagata un
certo punto la palla schizzata nel cielo
a caso via via via via via via così via
così ancora un gol dai buttata dentro è
72 contro uno li paro da cioè la parata
dai zio joe controllo non mi fate ridere
2 contro 1 bravi spingete io rimango qua
a difendere perché se schizza in avanti
un casino
bravi bravi ma arriva nel mezzo la butto
perfetto cristo velato che tiro perfetto
41 attenzione fantastico detto parole
per gilardino ci arriva potere anche
vicino alla bandierina circa 141 dentro
del piero del piero
davvero
del piero alex del piero
chiudete le valigie andiamo a berlino
gli apre oggi la coppa se eliminati
se eliminati fuori dalle balle fuori
dalle balle morite tutti quanti gli
eletti belli siro dentro il 41 ha senso
è finita lolletti già non mi ricordo che
mi me perché non guardo molto il calcio
tra la nazionale però siamo in finale
mancano 7 nodi ma questo faccio schifo
io in questo faccio schifo ragazzi
questo perché ovviamente non ho mai
giocato già cancellato prima non l'ho
fatto per niente schifo ho fatto bene
però non avendolo mai giocato non solo
tattiche rai proviamo come prima i sei
siamo in sette in sette siamo in sette
madonna e poco e sette ragazzi sono
veramente in meno di prima
quindi speriamo mi vada bene oddio
carlton caduto qua no no no mi sono
buttato nel vuoto sono stupido come la
morte nera maledizione alla mia vita
vabbè non importa tanto l'importante è
rimanere sull'esterno tanto gli altri
cadono bisogna prendere vantaggio nel
tempo ragazzi sotto gioco nel tempo cioè
nel mentre che gli altri saltano
buonissimo buonissimo che io questo qua
no no no ma che cacchio faccio un
livello benissimo e poi le perdo 1
faccio un livello benissimo e ne perdo 1
questa è la mia capacità ragazzi perché
li ho fatti benissimo quelli di prima
maledizione alla mia vita e niente caso
anche quando peccato però vabbè
ma anche a poca roba l'importante è
riuscire a fare il giro per bene adesso
tanto mancano ancora troppi i livelli
se riesco a fare un giro per bene qua ci
deve essere una tattica che non so e non
è vero come ho fatto a cadere lì cacchio
fate cazzi toi schifoso ma che cazzo ma
ora sto pezzente maledetto stronzo ma
cosa vuoi
ma cosa vuoi da la vita mia ma ammazzati
ma oggi suicidi tifo ma non ho capito io
lo so di aver sfruttato uno qui o dio
dio dio che cos'è beh chi è questo noi
ragazzi siamo in troppi aiuto ma
l'evoluzione alla mia vita maledetta
schifosa laida maledetto il carnevale di
viareggio perché perché perché
uno guarda ma perché perché sono caduto
come un idiota
la cosa [ __ ] e che nel tirare il pugno
alla tastiera
mi sono mutato e non avete sentito
niente
e aggiungerei meno male
meno male che non avete sentito niente
perché mi sono decisamente incazzato
comunque stavo dicendo che sono un
fenomeno
nell'ultimo gioco solo nelle piattaforme
sono che quando caldo cadeau due volte
c'è non è che io faccio una piattaforma
tutta tutta la faccio tutta bravissimo
doppio del power il power italiano visto
gioco bellissimo poi quando caldo cadeau
due volte caldo in quella dopo cado
quello dopo ancora mandato affanculo non
vale sono caduto tre volte così tre
volte sono caduto due volte sono caduto
dalla piattaforma e poi quella stoffa
ancora due volte così andate a cagare
non vale sono un fenomeno in quello se
non cadesse due volte di fila
meno male che non avete sentito a fango
la storia da noi ragazze ragazzi ora non
so cosa dire non so cosa dire
[Musica]
arrivo sempre in finale giorni a guardar
non so non solamente cosa dire perché
male rete che arriva in viale nuova
realtà
non c'è niente anzi ci sono stato tre
volte bellissimo come venuto in mente
quello vasta devi rallentare ho capito
però il problema è che quando io cado
cadeau due volte se io non calessi la
seconda volta sarà mai vintage anche per
anche prima avrei vinto perché sono
caduto due volte anche il finale io non
caldo sulla tutti la piattaforma ha
calcato dopo la prima che cazzo quindi a
quel punto arrivati alla penultima
piattaforma mi conviene stare sopra non
mi conviene non mi conviene neanche
stare sulla mia piattaforma comune che
guardi già dove sotto c'è il buco perché
se non cado 18 che palle maledizione è
stata sia comunque incredibile gli ho
tirato più pugni che ha preso più pugni
questa che mike tyson e la galia sua non
ho sbagliato ho cambiato il pattern per
lo sporcato questo nodo che ha cambiato
il pattern soste chiazze sembra una
porcata strana una mucca con la va bene
lo cambiano di nuovo ragazzino mi piace
21 prima però va bene che sfiga raga se
non fosse stato per quella ori vinto
anche stavolta
mannaggia un ragazzo mi ricordo se
volete supportarmi con la sua facciata e
farmi la domanda vi rispondo ma in live
senza problemi o poi super sticker
sempre cose
oppure abbonandovi al canale avete visto
in anteprima e bari e varie altre cose
oltre che essere salutati da me
ovviamente in live come ringraziamento
quindi fatemi sapere tanto potete usare
le mie moggi nella super chat e
schiacciate sul tasto e monici sono le
mie facce potete usarle spalmate quelle
sbagliate perché se non vuoi capire
bella tutti i ragazzi come del sindh e
giacomo my brother grazie mille frate
primi nove che la prima società credo
che alla prima non si impegnino comunque
tutti perché sanno anche gli altri che
non è difficile però però ragazzi vorrei
veramente trovare una tattica per la
fina che poi comunque è bellissimo
perché ti ho detto che colorano la roma
impatta anni è successo a due volte di
fila come finale che e cattivi spiega os
arrivati in finale tre volte ho fatto
tutte le partite che ho fatto sollevato
in finale cioè ma ragazzi quasi tutte
tranne una
angelo argomenta giacomo migliori
migliore web grazie mille per la
donazione di pak doo ghana grazie alla
donazione
andrea loffredo grazie al caffè grazie
mille ragazzi che sono un sacco comunque
guardate le skin ragazzi sono bellissime
c'è le skin che tipo di sbloccare adesso
ovviamente siamo tutti i quali gioco
uscito da tre giorni siamo tutti quanti
a livello minimo quindi non abbiamo le
skin incredibili però se vedete dalle
foto ci sono e ci saranno delle sim
pazzesche pazzesche perché ho fatto bene
come gioco che linea palla nella tua
area dei guadagna punti per il tuo team
il tuo team let's golf
spero di questa qualora questa non è
facile vi dico la verità bisogna
semplicemente tenere più palla è
possibile nella nell'area
la tua questo è basta non è niente di
strano
il problema è che ovviamente un sacco di
gente che le spinge nella propria area
quindi è un po un casino ora presso
siamo 3 noi perfetto l'abbiamo uno deve
rimanere in base a tenerle rimango io
perché so già che nessuno degli altri
rimane quindi rimango io in base nostra
tenere le palle perché sennò è un casino
i rossi sono tutti da noi come abbiamo
una sola noi ma che cacchio 2 abbiamo i
blu ne hanno cinque i blu ne hanno
ovviamente 5 quindi che cazzo venite
tutti da noi andate dai blu cosa vengono
i rossi da noi i blu ne hanno cinque ne
hanno 5 andate dai blu cacchio di rossi
maledetti andate dai blu ne hanno 5 di
palle 5 sono tantissime 4
ok perfetto buttate tutto lì la 30
secondi rimanenti sono tantissimi
ragazzi di 30 secondi com'era stato
proprio perfetto come posso riuscito 2
siamo veramente al rischio era veramente
liberi blu le palle ed il blu rimangono
ovviamente benissimo nella stabili nella
loro zona le nostre vacillano
maledizione 33 attenzione tra tre miglia
che colpo di testa pazzesco c'è
shevchenko pazzesca sta roba perfetto 10
secondi i rossi sono a zero teoricamente
abbiamo vinto a meno che non succeda
capo calisse nucleare che dovremmo aver
fatto uno proprio lui
cesena di grande grinta e giacomo myblog
anche se per laborazione vada bene anche
quest'anno anche alla riga reggio ma
magari sì anche se ft beh quest'anno c'e
gia stato un dono anno a questo a noi
c'era già la quarantena regalo anche
carte di te con questi ci vengo quasi
ogni anno e che dire ma avevo a che cosa
cento adesso permette a caso prima è
bellissimo ragazzi sembrano abbassata
roba
vi prego basta la discesa di frutta e
orribile ero bellissimo regalo
cosa succede se finiscono tutti in
parità e se finiscono tutti in qualità
ragazzi si va ai supplementari primo che
porta una palla c'è il primo che perde
una palla bella frase la linea
soprattutto per i maschietti mi
dispiacciono intendevamo quello che
pensa
perde quindi se siamo 3 3 e 3
il primo che la perde e viene eliminato
quindi va ai supplementari come rocket
league e ragazzi e allora fantastica che
sarò io sto gioco fatto sempre cagare
sempre la tattica che sto utilizzando e
rimanere al lato per evitare la maggior
parte della frutta e baffa è chrome e il
[ __ ] vita ma ci pare la frutta e
il tronco in mezzo vedete il tronco
quello fa un danno incredibile se
rimanete in mezzo vi prendete tutte le
bordate prima di vederlo sempre in mezzo
quindi era una tattica pessima bisogna
rimanere molto più a lato e vedete che
funziona ragazzi oggi il gioco più bello
del mondo è uscito speciali in live
spettacolare è bello quando partì giochi
che ti piacciono e non per fare di sma
ragazzi io quello lo faccio sempre in
realtà questo qua è un gioco che mi
piace e che fabius perché un gioco per
pazzesco tutti quelli che hanno fatto
hanno fatto un sacco di louis park è un
gioco in che è un gioco incredibile
tutti quelli che hanno giocato hanno
fatto views su youtube di guerra quindi
per me non è un peso portarlo e
bellissimo tranne quando mi fanno
incazzare però vabbè tanto si muoverà il
mio team
se muoio io vorrei anche molti muoiono
non è che mi fanno incazzare apposta
voglio dire ce li mettete pure voi
quindi giocate bene e comunque tante non
mi è mai successa così tante volte st
modalità che colpo di testa pazzesco del
pari però viene parato incredibile due
palle lì rimangono il mezzo che se
qualcuno perché la tattica buona qualche
quando una palla sta per entrare ce ne
si accorge che tipo adesso la butti
subito di la fera appena arriva
quest'altra guarda è dov'è eccola qua
perfetto vedi che prendi subito
vantaggio è utilissima st tattica sempre
nel mezzo a buttare palla in avanti
quando si segna però dovete segnare
ragazzi sono tutti in difesa occhio dai
dai dai ragazzi bravi bravissimi che gol
ok in meno e mezzo bravi ragazzi e
buttiamo lì a mezzo subito bravi così si
gioca kaki ocmin fate un giorno a voi
fate impazzire bravi
è così che si gioca colonna sonora
tagliamo che ci copia di sfruttare no no
no no no vi prego vi prego togliete
anche questo almeno madonna che brutta
roba ho visto mi è rimbalzata addosso
regala fatto io a cagata stavolta
bravissimo pro buttato in avanti ci ho
fatto la cagata ma ho fatto anche un gol
quindi uno a uno per me palla al centro
ok vai vai allora ce n'è uno solo in
difesa
minchia che cazzo e ha tirato un calcio
che manco veramente cr7 com'è possibile
io valuto con la palla si muove di un
millimetro vanno la toccano gli altri è
un super santos
ma cos'è spingete 4 blu lì è un giallo e
la palla sta rotolando versione spingete
maledetto i so io ok
bravo bravo 3 1 bravo bravo come giocate
bene moon gravissimi minchia suarez
bravissimi chiamate scatta terzo in
transitati la testa su perfetto perfetto
prova con la germania insiste foschi
cannavaro insiste ancora paloschi
cannavaro cannavaro bianca sta bene per
tutti niente potrebbe girarlo girargli
la paterna che dice ma bandierina cerca
l'uno contro uno dentro del piero del
piero
e andiamo a berlino ragazzi non l'ho
visto che era in minoranza qua e forse
la vampa ri non sono però avete se ne
frega eravamo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 6 8 contro
7 e quindi alla fine maggioranza noi
questa cosa non va bene secondo me
comunque quando e dispari devono mettere
una patch quando gli spari non puoi
mettere due team 1 ultimi contenuti non
lo puoi mettere perché e 1 ace ma basta
sto gioco basta sempre questo come
finale basta non solo non solo capace io
a fare questo basta a mettermi qua in
finale non sono in grado di farlo punto
la donna se perquai finale ma qua
mantenute anche questo l'impianto te
pareva ok ok ok
scusate se non leggo subito allora sei
ragazzi fisco questo e leggo tanto non
vinco uno su otto
mamma mia che finale pazzesco ecco dei
livelli che catolino è sempre di due
sempre di due quando io cado non campata
guarda guarda guarda che guarda che cado
di 26 piattaforme di fila
guardalo su tutto lui prima poi rimango
qua adesso ci rimango un'ora e quando
kato 18 nel giallo cadeau due volte
sempre e solo così ragazzi imbarazzante
non capisco il motivo non lo capisco
veramente mi rifiuto di capirlo è
veramente assurda sta roba se ci penso
faccia cadere in due piattaforme ogni
volta impossibile ma questo basta
cornello non soffre l'altro
madonna cosa ho fatto
madonna ma dove ho fatto una roba
incredibile bravissimo va bene non sono
caduto di due piattaforme che è
incredibile
e veramente un grande traguardo per me
c'è gente ancora sotto quella che se
caso quando di sotto ancora detenzione
molto bene fa vj molto bene il pari
molto bene il papi ok occhio qua è
l'occhio qua mi butto già di nato
minchia c'era un tizio siamo in due e
sono riusciti a beccare unico lato delle
notizie
questo è l'ultimo è mancano i quali
quattro siamo attenzione insomma che
saltava più veloce saltando ma se prima
si va più veloce esaltanti che non
sapevo in chiesa besco che valesse
ottima praga mancano tre persone no no
ma già il tasto mannaggia al cazzo sono
saltati sono saltati dei tasti della
tastiera
cos'è questo è un più dove cazzo ma il
più è saltato saltata la tastiera 8 ok
[Musica]
no abbiamo avuto un problema tecnico
ricominciamo ragazzi c'è stato un attimo
di non so come mai c'è un partitone
[Musica]
grazie mille marika gas e mille tinu per
la nazione ed ocse welcome idee
pangrazio mai brava o distrutto la
tastiera meno male che gioco con
joystick
ma va bene
minchia videocamere personaggi sono
allenamento ricordata da fango la sword
e allora non è norma allora tutte le
partite sono da 60 giocatori io arrivo
sempre tra i primi tre come cazzo è come
è sta roba era comunque una tattica
giusta ho scoperto due cose la prima se
mi tuffo ci metto più tempo ad alzarmi e
l'altra cosa è che saltando 20 veloce io
lo sapevo e comunque secondo me quando
arrivi alla fine all'ultimo pattern ti
conviene tantissimo arrivarci prima
perché se sei sulla seconda piattaforma
e non sull'ultima e gli altri sono gli
assoluti ma poi quando cadi da qua cadi
direttamente poi perdi
sembra cagata ma conviene rimanere
ultimi christian juncker grazie mille
per la donazione fratello
niente questo è successo a livello 9
miss blocco questo non ci tengo in
realtà
preferisco molto di più questo perché
qua sono robe che this gotico livelli e
dal taglio non i livelli non non c'è da
farci arrivare fino al 40 figo non lo
sapevo niente cambio personaggio voglio
la terza cacchio di corona per prendervi
questo non la prendono grazie dinu la
donation e niente riproviamoci mannaggia
la pupazza che doveva posso fare
qualcosa con le monete normali pc
perfetto non lo prendono però sono cose
che non mi servono in realtà le sue
niente christian malcolm in da giacomo
my brother grazie mille
io veramente voglio morire
no ragazzi veramente non mi basta fargli
fare quella cacchio di finale lino la
pasta adesso a noi data adesso posso
farlo perché so come si gioca però l'ho
dovuta fare tre volte non sapevo fare
solo quello guardate che di finali ce ne
sono tante non è che c'è solo quella
della caduta
ce ne sono 4 5 sempre quella ce ne sono
a volte al cinema dove devi fare un
percorso ostacoli la mia preferita che
sono bravi noi precorso ostacoli c'è
quella della coda che avete visto
all'inizio dove vivere l'ultimo con la
coda che è stata la prima c'è questa che
l'avete vista tre volte ce ne sono
tantissime perché è sempre quella che
cazzo me ne frega a me di quella dove
cadde è l'unica che non so fare
mannaggia sempre terzo che poi mi fa sto
facendo un sacco di punti perché arriva
la terza è impossibile quindi io sto
facendo tanta roba
però voglio arrivare primo cattedra in
live arriva il terzino nel male per
niente guadagni tanti ragazzi ora niente
un sacco di punti col social comprarmi
una skin quei punti compreso e
tantissimo
però secondo vale solo a bocce quindi
oggi si vince e io non stanno finché non
vinco signori si vince per la vittoria
toglietevi ha poi tenere fermi gli altri
volendo tipo così però non è una cosa
che mi piace fare il mart che assieme
produzione non è una roba che mi piace
fare perché quando me la fanno a me io
spacco il joystick e le già successo
l'hanno già lanciato quello della
playstation una volta quindi la perché
non gioco anche sulla playstation sto
gioco e non voglio rifarlo visto che
costano i joystick rock una donazione
ragazzi per riprendermi giorni se lo
lancio
no comunque vedi che il primo round è
veramente io nelle corse a ostacoli poi
me la cavo sempre perché comunque è
strano perché non avete visto come
finale quasi solo quello dove cadde e
come inizio solo questo
e ce ne sono tantissimi tantissimi avete
visto solo quello che avete sfiga perché
ce ne sono tantissimi randomicamente
all'inizio mentre sempre questo ma non
c'è solo questo la sicuro c'è soltanto
da voi avete sempre sono meno cari la
prossima sarà diversa
certo giuseppe cassini per ansia saluto
anche lorenzo grazie mille un bacio
fidatevi
fidatevi che ce ne sono tanti non ci
sono quelle di quello che è passato
adesso non so se l'avete visto quello
delle porte beh vedete quanta roba c'è
ce ne sono tantissimi e voi avete visto
come inizio solo quello
e molto bello ma sempre quello non ha
senso quindi spero che la prossima ce ne
sia uno nuovo
speriamo in un finale nuovo adesso
mannaggia il cacchio lo ci siamo o
queste slang climb questo è un percorso
a ostacoli in salita ragazzi l'ho fatto
una volta sola non è così difficile però
l'ho fatto una volta sola quindi non
tanto non ho ben capito si qualificano
in 35 perché non ho capito se cadi viene
eliminato direttamente on off
questa cosa quando capo bella stata la
[ __ ] che poi va detto con sotto come
niente quindi non è proprio tempo
destinato a ok ok molto bene molto bene
molto bene molto bene
aiuto perfetto posso salire di qua no mi
piacerebbe stato per gli era un'ottima
tattica però è passatemi la la tattica
perché non era male che cazzo togli
chiave riesco a salire ok meno male che
anche un sacco di altra gente non è
riuscito a salire vuoti sono solo in due
davanti all'amica che viene molto di più
ingente che vai vai vai i primi 33 si
classificano ai ragazzi non ho ben
capito se qua ragazzi rimane gente fuori
dalla classifica o no
cioè non ho ben capito se che si
classificano tutti tranne quelli che
cadono oppure se rimane gente fuori
credo rimanga gente fuori perché 33 sono
dati al e su sono 23 adesso sono di meno
prima ad essi qualificati diminuiscono a
cazzo perché è per quale motivo è molto
bene molto bene
non so strafare va bene
ancora che ci sono arrivato alla fine a
uno sì che sto aspettando e poi ci sono
bello no minchia minchia no tua madre
che quella che fa le sedie aiuto cielo
no ce l'ho fatto straw vivo togliti
testa di vecchia ci sono state chi
guarda guarda c'è quello lì che rimane
lì fermo per fermare gli a chi sta bene
ti sta bene
cornuto guarda che è cascato guarda gli
sta bene è cascato di sotto perché
quello stalin fermo al traguardo a
fermare gli altri l'avete visto la
l'avete visto l'ha buttato giù la palla
ma lista solo bene the morire mori
maledetto c'è ma vi fa the world
dimettesse deve far morire la gente
perché è arrivato al traguardo lui sa
che è qualificato e si ferma e tiene la
gente ferma ma può una cosa tiene in
tasca ma ammazzati ci avevano capito
puntati chiude sotto infatti andato il
risotto perché l'ha buttato la palla ma
te lo meriti
schifoso maledetto su core nudo questo è
il karma carmassi ma alle volte non
certo karma il fatto e quello alle volte
cade gente perché la gente la ferma al
traguardo ma dai ma potete se così si
scoprì maledetti
no mica il ponte di prima
siamo in 14 raga è sempre in finale vado
è incredibile questa non è la finale
questa semifinale
bisogna e vengono classificati in otto
ok e qua bisogna trovare il patto giusto
quindi il percorso giusto vai
la tattica aspettare che vadano gli
altri e poetico fido però tanto
all'inizio non vale niente perché
all'inizio mentre tutto dritto e tutto
dritto regalo è tutto dritto regalo no
no qualcuno si butti qualcuno si butti 4
consecutivo a qualcuno si può fidare
sacrificatevi io non mi posso buttare
anche se li porto io
se puntato giovanni ok ok qualcuno trovi
la strada ma c'è non c'è la strada è che
cacchio cacchio buttatevi no testa di
minchia che mi aspetta
ma adesso la trovano adesso la trovano
me lo dicono guarda ex mola trovano lo
sapevo io lo sapevo
sono stato due ore e mezza su sta minkia
mi hanno spinto ma [ __ ]
sono stato due ore due ore e soprani
maturo ma dai ma dà mandato a cagare
morina quando morì temo io sono morto
per niente sono morto per niente perché
sono caduti dai
ma non ne frega dell'ex up [ __ ]
ero fermo lì ero fermo da due ore non
hanno trovato una strada in due ore due
arrivo mi spingono ex è caduto ecco la
strada è certo facile così teste di
minchia dunque su arrivato infine in
semifinale che non è male ma raramente
mi che così si gioca una finale in 33
gradi 4 pensate non eravamo neanche in
semifinale ai terzi a grandi 3 min
chiamavamo in 14 aran trema e pochissima
non si arriva mai in 14 erano tre
pazzesca sta roba
figo e dove vanno così fratellino
dovranno così fratelli e 17 27 coat i
fratelli e questa è così
no comunque cosa volevo dire fa niente
c'è nel senso che non si potrebbe alla
fine proprie sfiga che sfiga son rimasto
fermo due ore e mezza hanno trovato la
strada proprio quando sono morto io e
figure quando da the door dash questo è
bello allora questa non è la partenza
solita questa partenza diversa questo è
e questo è takeshi's cast questo ogni
livello vita che si scassa il prezzo è
preso importato direttamente ci sono c'è
il traguardo alla fine c'è un percorso
di forte alcune vere alcune finte quelle
finte ci sbatti la faccia e rimangono
ferme con le vere si sfondano tu devi
trovare quella giusta e malta
la tattica qua è ovviamente far andare
gli altri vedere
sono vere crisi non è venuto non c'è
niente di troppo strano questo era un
perfetto aspetto che si schianta il
tucano e poi vado io
bravo du camp che curò la beccate tutte
ma che non è facile quella quanta gente
in realtà dietro bravo mi chiama tutte
le pecche che cacchio è nostradamus
nostra tuca ecco non devo far cuocere
una sola ok sono primo addio 50 per
cento
eccolo 1 per cento
no che testata finale ho dato una
testata finale totale alla porta cioè va
bene basta arrivare questa questa
bellissima questa qualità e bellini è
una delle mie preferite in assoluto come
round all ok a s'inquadra eliminato un
sacco di gente primo round ragazzi
lamenta se ne va
il primo round un sacco di gente se ne
va da 60 il 38 vai è questo ragazzo è
così e 17 27
[Musica]
anyway grazie ragazzi per tutto il
supporto per le api per gli abbonamenti
per le donazioni per il super per la sua
chat di supersic air grazie miei ragazzi
di supporto se avete supportarmi sono i
tassi di solito potete farlo
la buona la fonazione la votazione la
potete fare solo da desktop non da
mobile soprattutto invece potete donare
anche al gol di cristiano ragazzi questa
è la mia tattica
ditemi voi se non è infallibile poi
quando l'unico se cosa in genere muoio
però questa cosa ve l'ho già fatta una
decina di volte non sono mai caduto
ormai vengono eliminati in 16 e io non
sono mai caduto una volta praticamente
funziona proprio la mia tattica per bene
ok di switch strasse 2
e fantastico la gente invece sale che
cazzo vuoi tu dovevi le mani verso
quelle liguri the money maledetto è una
tattica che funziona abbastanza
addirittura poi rimanere sullo stand o
se lo stesso non può rimanere perché se
non c'è il gruppo puoi saltare il buco
ma è un rischio un po troppo grande che
non ha senso secondo me non ha senso che
usato luogo dov'è buco
togliti è vecchio come me vedo del muro
ok perfetto
questa è buona da deboli maria chiave
boni tutti maurizio costanzo ovunque non
abbiamo il collo valero tutti maurizio
costanzo negato guarda bellissimo
meraviglioso
voglio la skin di ma no mica cadevo
voglio la skin da maurizio costanzo su
folgaria
voglio poi costanza bellissimo la
comprerei subito anche a 50 euro ma i
premi ok duri a morire store a un dei
ragazzi bravi tra amiche ha registrato
tutti 12 e meini 12 4 lemeni 12 caduti e
basta mica sono tutti pro gamer ciccone
successo file costanzo bellissimo led
che mancano tueni per traditi allora ora
adesso che siamo in parità
secondo me un team contro un team ci sta
undici contro undici a poco se siamo in
23 non puoi fare 15 contro 12 che merda
perché non ha senso vediamo se c'è casa
romana ok quello di prima
il rock and roll questo devi portare la
palla alla fine avevo detto prima
non arrivare ultimo quindi l'obiettivo
io non sono mai arrivato primo qua mai
arrivato primo primo vuol dire che metti
la palla subito in cane in porta e vedi
poiché cosa fanno gli altri che 2t si
combattono non sono mai arrivato primo
sarebbe molto interessante arrivare con
iniqua
se fai velocissimo quali di primo il
problema che è molto difficile arrivare
primi in questo tipo i rossi sono già 28
il mercato è 28 per cento
i blues sono lenti come la quaresima qua
quindi teoricamente la danno indietro i
blu dai che forse ce la facciamo
dai che forse eravamo dai che forse ce
la fa mo lo chiamo tutti i blu ragazzo
una 18 sono 18 rossi bloccati blu locali
ma sono 18 ae luciano va sotto con rossi
de rosso del cazzo che siamo a 63 tutti
e due vice suoi blu ma quanto c'è di
quoziente intellettivo 0,5 è il blu sono
ancora lì sopra blocca lui cosa blocchi
me ma guarda che idiota e ci arrivi blu
sulla sono di sopra i blu ancora con lo
bloccavano ragazzi la gente che gioca
sto gioco gli avrei non ho idea
mancano 15 playa perfetto 15 players
abbiamo fatto tre ancora due partite ci
sono minchia questa difficile perché 15
e dispari final round in 15 mar abbiamo
già fatto cinque mi chiamo sopportare
siamo al finale ragazzi in 15
vabbè questa festa è la navata ancora
vista finalmente un finale diverso in 15
questo è difficilissimo poi non parto
per primo devi arrivare alla fine
prendere la corona la corona che mi
sarebbe sbloccare la skin [ __ ] se
riuscisse a prendere quella maledetta
corona let's go vince il primo non ci
sono se condite che bordello che
bordello finale sono in svantaggio tanti
sono praticamente quasi ultimo ok ok mi
ci aspettiamo che porca [ __ ] visto una
palla di cannone portiere ma non leggono
mai ragazzo purtroppo indietro sotto di
1 i tailleur e dal cazzo ti togliamo dal
cazzo studiamo la il cazzo ti tagliamo
del cazzo
no noi ci teniamo a parte
[Musica]
niente ragazzi non solo da dire c'è
questo presto questo ci sta che al
quarto ora vedi che non eravamo fatti 5
avevamo fatto 44 quindi io pensavo che
si arrivasse in finale sempre con cinque
round invece non sia di vantare anche un
4 round
ok io questa cosa non la sapevo però non
ha senso secondo me arrivare in 15 in
finale troppo pochi c'è troppo troppi
scusami troppi pochi round perché in
finale in dieci massimo ci può arrivare
noi 15 che piazza in bici in 15 finale
non puoi vincere 15 in finale 12 mai
c'è chi non puoi non è possibile in
dieci anche ancora infatti non ho capito
perché ha fatto solo quattro round
strano molto strano dunque quella della
corona è molto difficile ma non va
giocata in quindi secondo me sono
proprio tanti vabbè in 15 non puoi fare
una finale prova è sbagliata non mi
compravo aveva niente e nulla tanto
l'avrei perso lo stesso anche se non mi
avesse fatto poi di blogging con la
l'avrei perso uguale perché qua come ca
di una volta come ca di una volta hai
perso perché comunque su quindici
persone vuoi che qualcuno non la faccia
senza cadere quelli secchi di una volta
in finale ai già matematicamente verso a
meno che non ha il culo bestiale negli
altri caduti poi farsi colpire
dall'orologio secondo me i ragazzi non è
una punta in ere
queste mappe nuova non l'avete ancora
vista qua bisogna arrampicarsi per forza
e ci sono le pale eoliche devi passare
nel mezzo
se la gente non ti fa il cazzo di un po
di dubbio come sta succedendo adesso
quantica chi sono i tuoi la madonna
quanta gente c'è davanti ma come è
possibile
ma basta fare pochi blocchi toglieteli
dalle palle che due palle veramente che
cazzo 32 qualificarmi che sono veramente
forti politica di madonna come ho
rischiato pò a ragazzino vedere
eliminazione diretta
aiutami ci sono perfetto ok perfetto
fatte fatto non avrei vinto lo stesso
prima perché il tipo che mi facevo di
blocchi che comunque non era prima però
porca vacca matt giacomo thank you for
the donation mai prode chi è rimasto e
lavato org a caso visto
vabbè mi possono guardare lui non posso
cambiare personaggio che è andata in atc
su 60 già eliminati 20 più altri 9 31 m
perché comunque puntate che tanta gente
letta perché vede che non ce la fa
quindi per quella non vedete tutti gli
eliminati sul finale
molti hanno reputato già in partita
perché vedono che sono indietro e non ce
l'hanno fatta e quinn è stata una nuova
perfette match questo qua ragazzi
secondo me tra tutti è il più inutile e
il pin utile perché questo è un memory
sapete come memory allora sullo schermo
compare una frutta tra quindi secondi e
tu devi utilizzare dove quella frutta
poi ci sono una banale quindi qua in
mezzo
qua c'è la banana sono io adesso invece
cellula no perché la banana e davanti
cento
anche lì a sinistra quindi se li compare
un po banana io sto adesso a sinistra e
bagno finora tutto facile poi diventa
più difficile con papini metto fa poi
diventa più difficile perché poi
aumentano a metano frutta aumentano i
tasselli con più sul tah però i liberi
adesso ci auguriamo e ciliegia arancia
anguria rancia ciliegia sta qua
il problema è che ti da tempo di vedere
dove vanno gli altri beni anche se non
guardi dove vai comunque vinci padana
dove cazzo era mi metto qua guarda non
lo so però vedo tutti quando vanno qua e
mi metto va bene
e inutile suo livello perché non sapevo
dove la banana però vado dove vanno gli
altri e vede giusto quindi sbagliato
proprio come concetto qua vengono
eliminate solo due persone in genere
soventi è veramente poco
arancia frutta si farà già banana
l'anguria melarancia parlano ancora
melarancia parlando re nero arancio
banale
arancia banale di qua
devi anche se gli altri non guardo ok
non ho io veloso o vi giuro che lo giuro
su tutto quello che volete
sono morti tutti io sto gioco in questa
modalità non ho mai visto eliminate più
di due persone perché tutti si buttano
levano gli altri box tra ve lo giuro
cioè non ho mai visto incredibile mai
mai
che strano comunque vi giuro
e poi tra l'altro e poi tra l'altro con
tanti players quindi con 25 playas in
generale di milano 2
minchia quade roaming dati dieci minuti
sono rimasti in pochissimi sempre in
finale finisco ragazzi comunque non c'è
verso però il problema non è tanto
questo aveva vissuto dai jet fa niente
tanto siamo fare all'inizio però il
problema arriva in questa modalità che
qual caso sempre in qualche modo non si
sa con quali inizio ti puoi buttare
tanto maniera meno che non hanno uno
sfacciato tipo questo che non so come
sia possibile poi cadi per caduta nel
verbale si qualificano in sei veramente
pochi attenzione trovo la faccio la
prova del nove dai ci provo adesso vanno
tutti sul finale emilia non mi ricordo
più dove sono passati togliti no non mi
ricordo più dove sono passato che è
bravo bravo sì ricordato zio
l'ho giocata male perché perché io provo
a fare cose anche se teoricamente
dovrebbe spettare perché qual è la
tattica di sandali tanto devi aspettare
gli altri
ok perché gli altri si tuffano si
sacrificano che tu vai sul finale però
io dico se io mi tuffo quindi o il cui
il coraggio di tuffarmi mi merito di più
la vittoria degli altri perché ho avuto
un coraggio più grande riguadagnate però
non è meritocratico cioè nel senso ti
devi far i cazzi tuoi
si devono sacrificare gli altri e arrivi
alla fine quindi non ci avevo mai
provato è in realtà a buttarmi a cazzo
così cioè si ci prova ma all'inizio
quindi non lo farò più
adesso arrivo in quella modalità rimango
dietro a costo di stare così due ore e
mezzo aspetto che si buttino gli altri è
un po brutto secondo me è un po brutto
perché non è meritocratico
c'è chi si butta merita di vincere
perché quello che si fa più il culo e
invece non è assolutamente comunque
valeva niente ho voluto strafare perché
volevo provare a vedere se la tenacia
premia questo gioco
la risposta è no non premia un cazzo
però ci stava come testi che venivano da
poco sapevo che sarei finito così molto
freddo io so io veramente questo gioco
per me in the money ho fatto matteo mio
gioco
io non che magari questo perché le cui
cazzo di porte non salgono mai
[Musica]
minchia oddio cosa ho visto mi sono
vinto per miracolo i miei punti deboli
sono la salita lenta quella con la
frutta
questo è orribile e secondo me il finale
quello dove dove si staccano le
piattaforme è uno dei miei punti deboli
perché
arrivano in finale cioè non arriva mai a
vincere grazie ragazzi grazie per il
supporto poi geriani mai vinto sì
ragazzi allora è brutto che io ve lo
dica perché è bello che esca in un video
ho vinto a folger così vedete tutti la
mia vittoria ok tanto la vedete anche
oggi perché non me ne vado di gafi che
lo dico e me ne frega un cazzo
però è bello metterlo come titolo di un
video comunque la risposta è sì ho già
vinto due volte perché se vedete nel
menu io ho già due corone ho vinto due
volte a paul guys non ho registrato con
le due volte che ho vinto quindi non ci
sarà ancora un video di sta roba meno
atomico vincere qua oggi sono a me ne
vado e ho vinto ho vinto già due volte e
mi ha dato quindi due corone che posso
utilizzare per sbloccare roma però il
problema di faul guys e che perciò
trovati se non molto più di due corone
quindi almeno tre fare quello che vorrei
vedere adesso che è qui pugile e
bellissimo sono sbloccarlo adesso
problema che prenderebbero rischio gioco
e momento nel culo mica da ridere prof
allora tutti i gialli sono qua e hanno 5
valle come cazzo è possibile se sono
tutti in base a loro che hanno 5 valle
come fanno
non è possibile lo dico io sono il tutti
quanti nelle altre calcio di base
vedete che nella basi legali non c'è
nessuno e allora come cazzo fango ma da
avere cinque palle come lo dite voi io
non lo so i rossi in anno sei qualcuno
dei blu fa qualcosa possiamo giocare
insieme vorrei vincere questo gioco io
per favore qualcuno dovrebbe rimanere in
base nostra dipendere mentre gli altri
no però ok buono quello che cazzo fanno
disposto la bravo rosso bravo bravo
bravo tienimi testa di merda tanto perdi
ok bene bene bene ma poi alla fine
prendiamo noi perché dato addio rinvio
di scena tenete le palle ferme basta
bravi
minchia che ha buttato la palla
e basta
e stato bellissimo perché comunque la pa
allora le tattiche di quando fai il
gioco con le palle bellissimo
penso che quelle palle la tattica è uno
barra 2 barra 3 dipende quanti siete
rimangono in base un 30 per cento di
player 25 rimane in base a difendere le
palle
il resto va in attacco anche nel gioco
quello che sembrano che click
in difesa qualcuno ci deve stare e sono
la palla entra subito specialmente
quando cadde dal centro perché la tv
resta subito e va direttamente in porta
ma di qualcuno difesa sempre se non c'è
difesa c'è sconfitta subito questa frase
picchia incredibile le uova vj citazioni
di eventi sempre qualcuno in difesa
quando c'è un gioco con una palla
lì come casa si fanno quelli a saltare
sul ma bravi ma che figo quest'anno da
questa ecco questa è una tattica che non
sapevo che lì che c'è gente ci giocato
comunque almeno da tre quattro giorni da
quando uscì 10 gioco da ieri e ho
imparato quasi non tutto ma quasi sulle
sulle basi sulle prime tanti che però
tipo queste micro scorciatoie fanno la
differenza io non ne sapevo più che
altro io dovrei bisognerebbe chinarsi
bene sulle finali perché per arrivare in
finale io ci arrivo sempre perché le
tattiche le so google è quindi quasi
tutte quelle che sono state appurate
adesso nell'inizio vinci saranno per gli
avanti molte più tattico però quelle che
ci sono adesso le so quasi tutte quindi
dovrei scusarmi molto di più sul finale
vedi adesso sono secondo c'è vado
benissimo io qua
il finale che fa la differenza ragazzi
perché poi arrivare fino a quanto voi
vicino prendi più punti ma la vittoria
ti dà la gloria eterna il tuo nome verrà
ricordato per sempre e quindi questo se
mi blocca lo ammazzo
che bravo noi gli entrava in casa lista
kabul computer torino quindi importa
solo la bit solo la vittoria finale
perché tutto il resto non vali niente
lavitola finale è un master è di
riuscire a farlo è quanto di più utile
per adesso
arrivare alle finali è stato sempre un
po più lo scazzo fanno questi giro giro
tondo la ragazza guarda che se allora
trattenere gli avversari davanti al
traguardo vi fa tirare fuori un karma
pesantissimo e di valutare sotto ve lo
dico i ragazzi voi fate voi volete che
guarda quanta gente c'è ancora deve
arrivare al traguardo ora quanto c'è un
punto poco ci ho messo su uno speed
runner c'è ancora centre a classificare
ancora 7 da classificare e io sono
arrivato un'ora fa e gli altri non
accennano a muoversi quindi utilissimo
sono stato un mega bravo alla fine penso
che ci sia un tempo limite quindi gli
toglie gli toglie così che rimangono
indietro o altri letto 11 rimanenti
ragazzi mi sono perso ma alla lego dopo
grazie mille per adolescenti tanto
appena arrivo i lobi leggo per me costa
un po troppo suo gioco è gratis
c'è sul playstation nave gratis
normalmente costa 19 di marino ragazze
giusto che un prezzo giusto su pc costa
19 avevano mag ala fissa su playstation
now se avete playstation now
per questo mese solo per questo mese è
gratis quindi nel caso non playstation o
playstation plus volevo dire ho detto
messo su ansa.it e playstation plus è
gratis questo mese perché ho detto che
station aver sbagliato
bravi 10 ok io rimango qua spingente
spingete spingete come dei prudenti
qualcuno e di bravo fa vigeva che tiro
fa un fenomeno l'avete acampora mette
dentro e il buon fa vi era proprio che
la parata ai gialli bravo testa di
minchia avevo di giocare il a dirlo
subito non so perché per pc non sia
gratis per bene non l'ho capito penso
che sia un'esclusiva questo ci siano
accordi con playstation perché non l'ho
capita sarà buonissimo buonissimo basta
tenere in mezzo frate bravo bravo il
favi che la blog dove l'altra per fini
chiamato persona dice quello che
cassetto
ok ok tutto in tutti in regola fratello
tute regola fratte tutte regola frate il
fratello tutto in regola
tutto in regola 9 cazzo mi spingi c'è
solo da letto tuo compagno io ragazzi
dovete fare notare la palla milano di
qua minchia non ci voleva molto
bravissimi la padana le vie dentro e
sono quattro
un 40 micidiale il famila butta in mezzo
un po spericolata st palla sta dormendo
porca vacca ancora in difesa ce ne
stiamo vincendo contro zero nessuno in
difesa non ce la meritiamo perché in
difesa sempre qualcuno ragazzi sempre
qualcuno tutto se vado io sempre
qualcuno perché una ogni gol parato è
comunque il fatto alla fine quindi
rimani in difetto non spingerla qua
testa di dinosauro spinge a dylan file
ed è fred il welcome in del gioco ma il
bellissimo nome che mi tranquillizza tra
l'altro hanno detto che su sto gioco
faranno un sacco di skin anche a veri
che si può fare a fare le molte le mogli
le volte che volevo dire a giuliano
sacco il mio tuffo varrà meno degli
altri aggiungeranno un sacco di skin
tipo anche di faina dei freni starò
questo gioco sarà personalizzati simo
personalizzati nissimo questo devo dire
comunque ogni tanto di tuffo ci passa
attraverso la palla c'erano bene siamo 5
a 1 quindi sticazzi quello un po strano
che la roma è successa prima non c'è
contrasto 987 va bene 6 a 2
direi che è molto buono bravi ragazzi
siete piaciuti li siete veramente
piaciuti quanti rimaniamo alla fine sei
er avanti minoranza 12345 se no sei
contro sei contro cinque erano di
minoranza ma veramente ovviamente minora
meno male
ora che ho nemmeno fare
mister mi se ma esiste l'istat wacom
ingaggia gambaro royal rumble come prima
ma un buon numero mai capito come si
dice 5
tutti contro tutti ce la giochiamo per
la finale ragazzi ce l'ho io la coda non
vuol dire niente averla l'inizio ragazzi
perché tanto si perde tanto si perde in
due minuti la fai un file privata della
60 volta riguadagnava 60 volte non so
spero che non mi vedano non ho visto non
sanno né sono ragazzi mi nascondo ovvero
nuovo permesso che ridere pensa che
ridere se rimangono ragazzi ne vado
ho visto aiuto di chi sa se rimarrò no
ragazzi se rimarremo se rimaniamo fino
alla fine senza farmi vedere sarebbe
stata una roba da pro gamer totale
sarebbe stato incredibile peccato per
sta roba veramente allora vediamoli
resiste non ci ha provato ho già
resistito un minuto e tanti un minuto
con la coda è impossibile mela merito
già io per dirvi la partita però sto
gioco non è meritocratico mai quindi
però sicuro non vince non c'è non è
detto però non penso di vincere io
perché di giorno nè fermi ma dove cazzo
la cosa che sta un chilometro ma dove
bastava un chilometro quel male allora
prendeva pure a me allora è certo ma io
e lui stava lontano un chilometro e
mezzo ma dove ma quando
ma cosa mi ha preso ma non è vero mai ma
mai proprio ma no vabbè ragazzi mi
chiami cago addosso adesso vuol dire non
mi hai preso quello 37 secondi
chiamavano bravissimo bisogna utilizzare
le discese 29 raga
minchia pazzesco c'è un'ansia terribile
a noi sembra riprendi il nuovo distanza
evinto che non è giusto
no minchia sono caduto noti secondi non
ne ha presa non l'ha presa lui ma che
cazzo mi fermi a me lui ma sei un idioma
danno questo motore lavorando in coppia
no vabbè ragazzo che cazzo fermi ma che
cela lui che cazzo mi fermi ma cosa ma
ce l'aveva lui quello ma fermato ma cosa
chiami cosa minchia vuoi cosa vuole cosa
voleva quello a me che non ce l'avevo
già aveva l'altro non è meno ragazzi non
è meritocratico lo so non importa ci sta
che io abbia perso lo stesso non importa
a che cosa mi fermi che c'era lui la
coda che cazzo vuoi da me cioè non posso
che sta questa questa è non ho mai fatti
certo che me la meritavo io però non è
meritocratico sto gioco non lo è per
niente ma l'ho già detto prima
qua vince se io posso tenerlo anche un
minuto 59 e 1 mela può rubare per ultimo
ha vinto lui perché non è me non conta
quanto tempo la tieni conta quanto
quando c'è la controversia per ultimo
questo paper mette anche i giocatori più
scarsi di poter vincere
infatti io l'ho tenuta per un minuto e
venti io mi sarei meritato la partita
tutta però non ho vinto io perché una
bella ruba la fine l'altro mi tiene
chissà che cazzo ci ha guadagnato quello
che ha mantenuto che non ha vinto però
vabbè ma non è meritocratico però ci sta
a perdere perché comunque non
non vuol dire tenerla per più tempo
anche se la verità voglio
ovviamente però breve c'è il suo gioco
sono veramente secondo me la cavo
tantissimo cioè uno di quei giochi dove
minchia solo un fenomeno e non so perché
ci sono quei giochi del che
all'apparenza sono giochi del cazzo tipo
questo che però sono un fenomeno e poi
altra roba tipo da pro gaming
roba che vale che per i tornei tipo che
ne sono counter strike over worcester
nei quali faccio pagare però nei giochi
tipo questi sono un fenomeno non so come
mai ragazzi non ha senso lido gioco è
veramente strana sta roba
quindi sfruttiamola finché sono bravino
in questi rimaniamo in questi arrivato
quasi sempre in finale come ho detto
prima però vicino conta solo la voce
ragazza sola voce non ha saltato
adesso leggo e ragazzi scusatemi che
sono concentrato lo sa perché non ha
saltato
oddio non vedo l'ultima donazione non me
la fa vedere se ne arriva un'altra leggo
tutte e due se no devo aspettare la fine
del grande classe 1000 comunque nel
frattempo
era infatti ragazzi fare un sacco di
video su questo proprio perché me la
cavo
se c'è un gioco dove me la cavo tipo
roche click io me la cavo non sono non
sono fenomeni euro che se io perché ero
che league è un gioco ecco anche l'ok
etilico in gioco da tornei il gioco da
professionisti
io sono medio di bravura media normale
quindi non sono né scarsone forte la
dire minchia normale secondo me diamante
sono rancati diamante però fall guys
l'iran che non ci saranno mai creduto
però me la cavo parecchio bene perché
riesco sempre arrivare in finale poi
finale ve lo dico da culo cambiano non è
meritocratico anche prima vedete ho
giocato meglio io di tutti quanti messi
insieme però perso perché non vuol dire
niente con la che mi ha preso la coda la
presa negli ultimi 10 secondi non ha
fatto un cazzo tutta la partita quindi
l'iva culo però se melaka visto gioco è
giusto che io fa porti nei video perché
mica è l'unico gioco dove veramente ci
sono dentro parecchio e quindi è meglio
uno e difesa e rimango io se non rimane
nessuno se in due dai va bene
rimaniamo in tre in difesa però
rimaniamo c è qualcuno pensa a quella io
penso questa non posso pensare a due
palle io cazzo penso una sola ok ok io
penso a questa e voi pensate alle altre
bravi ragazzi bravi i rossi sono lì
bravi bravi tenete quale palle bravi
tengo io tengo io tengo io rimango io
difesa ragazzi nessun problema basta che
in attacco facciate qualcosa perché
difesa stati in due
bravo va bene così no no no no no no ma
[ __ ] minimazzato male
andate a prendere io rimango difesa
vedete che funziona così se gli altri se
gli altri sanno se ognuno fa il proprio
mestiere qua e vinta non ce n'è io
faccio il mestiere della difesa io
rimango in difesa gli altri devono solo
attaccare perché se io sono in difesa
insomma da solo gli altri qualcosa
saranno facendo immagino che adesso
stanno facendo qualcosa ci sono delle
volte in cui sono solo in difesa e
comunque di palle continuano ad averne
sempre zero e perdiamo
e vi chiedo come cazzo è possibile se io
sono in difesa gli altri cosa sta
facendo stanno giocando a fort nye cioè
perché non è possibile però se io
rimango in difesa e qualcun altro milan
con una mano gara non è male fate più
facile quindi qualcuno deve fare un
lavoro solo quello vedete funziona
tattiche tattiche su tap che comunque
qua l'eliminazione e una su tre perché
l'ex le squadre sono tre quindi viene
eliminato una squadra intera quindi è
una possibilità su tre di essere
eliminato questo gioco è difficile
ragazzi non era sicuro che arrivare in
fondo in finale non è facile velo
assicurati sono arrivato già cinque
volte in questa la juve è difficilissimo
arrivare in finale è difficilissimo
perché è come arrivare all'ultimo
cerchio di forza ed alla fine o dei
batteri royale in generale come arrivare
allo showdown non f
non è semplice quindi è importante
stiller see sulle per quanto sia
possibile sfidarsi sulle finali perché
io tipo alla fine prima quella di prima
le riguardate se volete potete rivederla
l'ho giocata benissimo l'ho giocata
benissimo potuto fare meglio qualcosa sì
ma ho giocato molto meglio degli altri e
o comunque perso perché non vuol dire
che vuol dire l'accumulo di finale val
curone cenere come un'estrazione alla
fine però giocare bene zio con
ottimamente alle proprietà detto è
quello 11 eliminati su 22 che siamo la
metà delle persone qua verrà eliminata
ragazzi venivano una possibilità su due
di essere eliminati juventus
togli di cristo ok ma veramente ancora
nisco chiami i ragazzi sto giocando con
dei pro gamer nessuno eliminato uno solo
minchia complimenti ragazze forti quello
che ho dovuto quasi madonna due
eliminati genere qua è quasi finita
invece mamma mia quanto durano questi
sono fortissimi
va bene ci sta ci sta questa quest'anno
giocata benissimo sono stati bravissimi
e ammetto la sconfitta bravo questa sono
stati veramente non cadeva nessuno non
so come sia stato possibile in genere
cadono tutti a manetta lì è
difficilissimo sul marmo e ragazzi e
molto benefici a livello che è sempre lì
sono stati bravissimi loro niente niente
da dire completamente bravi bravi
complimenti dove niente da dire ripresa
f tu fai respect ragazzi preserre tube
respect sono stati molto bravi ma lì non
ho potuto dire niente nel bulbo erano
molto bravi
basta bravi ci sta next next next messo
schiantato per esempio tube rispetto
detto schiantato fratelli non ho era le
la giusta quella gennaio la vinco sempre
però stavolta qualuno riva nessuno porca
vacca complimenti bravi fino adesso fino
adesso forse questa è l'unica sconfitta
tra tutte fra nel finale
finale con me la meritavo le molte
difendere però quest'altra tra le non
finali è l'unica che veramente mi
meritavo di riuscire io perché gli altri
sono stati molto più bravi non si poteva
dire un caso di stato molto dura però
apro peccato la compagnia di pro gamer
di follia perché non ho mai solo un gene
sono tra i più forti delle partite
sempre sempre non c'è o hanno avuto culo
perché erano timbra vi bastano
generativo sempre finale praticamente
sempre strano figo bravi e mi stavo
dicendo comunque quella roba lì
e semplicemente tempismo perché la
lancetta di sotto si muove più lenta di
colari sopra fini non dovete può essere
dovete scendere dev'essere defenestrati
ora vedete sono sempre tra i primi
quando avete visto e fermando tra è
arrivato e anche e anche e anche stupida
la gente che si ferma alla fine e anche
stupida per motivo perché la gente che
si ferma alla fine prende meno punti
perché se tu arrivi terzo io sono
arrivato terzo su 60 adesso che è
incredibile
prendo tanti punti quindi alla fine
partita quindi sono stupidi quelli che
si fermano perché prendono meno punto
non so quanti pro meno sacrificano punti
per fare
dimissioni subito f.to bene specie ai
ragazzi
se l'unico che ammette le sconfitte
giuste quando è no ma è vero mi che
primaria la società di bravissimi quella
della coda per me è una vittoria mia
quella della quota mi sono nascosto 20
secondi non abbiamo anche trovato un
fenomeno io l'ho ottenuta un minuto
correndo sono stato lì per me a
moralmente l'ho vinta io poi l'ha data
un altro che l'ha tenuta per due secondi
però lì non ce n'era ce l'ho giocata
meglio di tutti quanti però la vittoria
ripeto ragazzi non è meritocratica per
niente ma veramente ha chiuso ma va
niente c'è il giusto così sto gioco non
è un gioco di e sport
ci sta che va da culo va bene eccolo e
rende molto randomico il gioco stesso
lamento cuba ciliegia una ciliegia ok
ciliegia qua una davanti futuri papà
papà papà papà molto difficile ma molto
figo proviamo ma quasi 10 davanti allora
e non sai mai giusto no comunque mi sono
preso sai che mi stavo per andare
davanti
meno male che non sono andato davanti
mela banana me l'anguria mela banale me
l'anguria ok ok mela banana mango letta
rimaniamo qui vediamo
dove cazzo e la ciliegia mi butto dove
si buttano gli altri tattica master
tattica master non avevo neanche vista e
una ciliegia mi sono buttato dove si
sono buttati gli altri
questa è la tattica di questo gioco
ragazza da eliminare perché non ha senso
come anguria mela uva anguria mela una
banana 2000 una banana banana auguri a
me era una banana
ok arancia amara la lancia quella
sinistra di ragazzi è stata minata un
sacco di gente ma non ho capito perchè
perchè mi sa che c'è poco spazio
non perché
[Musica]
no non perché la gente non si ricordava
perché c'era poco spazio perché eravamo
con queen 32 in genere sorprendenti
sopra quella fattivamente provvedi che
comunque su 32 sono stati inviati in sei
sono pochissimi sono veramente pochi
larga in serie su 32 molto pochi quindi
un gioco che devono nato intorno all'ora
troppo senso sempre molto facile vederli
e no ragazzi provateci curva provate
cento giocato gioco fidatevi che ci sono
un miliardo di tattiche non è pari non
le sono anche tutte le son molte infatti
arrivo sempre in finale perché me la
cavavo perché ne sono molte ma non le so
neanche tutte non è facile ve lo
assicuro che è difficilissimo vincere
voi è impossibile perché siamo in 60
praticamente viene bbc1 60 in forti
night se sei porte vinci quasi tutto
perché sei forte ok qua no perché non
minchia colera giallo qua no perché il
finale va culo se sei bravo arrivi in
finale quasi sempre dipende anche se
campi di in una squadra di merda
però se sei bravo arrivi in finale quasi
sempre però non vi non è detto che tu
vinca
quello che cambia è quello che cambia
non ho preso un cazzo di cerchio neanche
uno ok ho preso io quindi qui dà voce ai
ragazzi la separazione ragazzi adesso
leggo certi disco nicolò intanto grazie
alla donazione come 18
ci ha messo di minoranza ok cribbio
ma cosa ma dove mai quando perché dove
già due sono i gialli buttatevi rimane
quando mi fermo e vi tolgo e spuntano
altri si cerchi caso io vado solo dove
vanno i rossi solo dove vanno i rossi
vado
bisogna sparpagliarsi raga ma bisogna
sparpagliarsi punto è l'unico modo solo
avevano i rossi così siamo tutti fermi
quale lo stesso cazzo di punto via
rossini la vado io non c'è un rosso di
qua qua tutti i rossi devono esse perché
sennò dimezziamo i punti la tattica poi
rimanere equipara i qui distanziati
equidistante come è finita già da ogni
cerchio perché bisogna prendere più
certi possibile se non abbiamo vinto per
niente ma hanno solo due punti di
differenza basta un cerchio giallo due
cerchi normali non va per niente bene
punte giorni bile questo ragazzo
punteggio orribile gialli ci possono
prendere quando vogliono
basta un cerchio giallo ok scena davvero
giocata male questa perché bisogna stare
metano da una parte metà dall'altra se
stiamo tutti da una parte la metà dei
punti ci giochiamo 17 remaining i
ragazzi madonna ma è comunque una
squadra mi ha comunque ricordati
spendono per questo si fa sempre in tre
lo scaling welcome idee giacomo e prima
masoni in greg 90 cesano stesso letto
bene perdonami però eccomi de giacomo
masoni granger a roma masoni granger
scusa bloc party queste belle non avete
ancora visto questa carino praticamente
arrivano dei blocchi e te li devi devi
schivare ho notato che tu stai avanti
perché la gente tende a stare in più
indietro e più ti ammazzi con le persone
e peggio è
quindi è meglio rimanere davanti qua
fidatevi non troppo perché sono roba in
tempo proprio rimane avanti più guadagni
tempo perché la gente stati dietro stai
proprio avanti tanto hai tempo di vedere
dove esclusa almeno non stai ammazzato
con la gente e vai subito dietro il
blocco subito così ti togli la gente
perché lo prendi per primo gli altri si
ammassano dietro verifone gallo john è
utile occhio li vedi avanti e di quelli
invece sono stati presi cadono quindi
non ce la fanno a sopravvivere lo dico
io ok avanti ragazzi come vedete che
molto facile perché loro tendono a stare
indietro perché si spaventano dei
blocchi e sbagliato è sbagliato perché
ti stai avanti e più sopravvivi fidatevi
a meno che uno non ti tenga fermo adesso
però testa di cazzo di uno zoo all'ami
ma che cacchio vuoi non serve a niente
trattenere suo gioco perché se cade uno
ok occhio lo occhio e di quanti sono
eliminati e io no io no ma vengono è
detto adesso probabilmente succedere
però se rimane avanti per di lama perché
la maggior parte della gente sia sassia
mamma saper progettare muto è sbagliato
qua qua ragazzi in questo punto più di
mai avanti migliori perché qua e il
diventa proprio difficile ti ammassi a
manetta guarda qua deve rimanere avanti
tantissimo perché si ammassano tutti a
manetta vuoi sei morto ma ci godo
tantissimo già vuole 8 eliminati
rimangono in otto teoricamente conti
siamo il 6 di c'eravamo eliminati quindi
rimangono otto credo da undici le mining
e non perché non è stato ok
no no perché se letti non ti con tale
tabellone anche sta roba se non appena
cagata a kinect ad almeno nel tabellone
secondo me lo puoi lasciare perché è
proprio bello vedere gente che cade se
letti non ti mette le tabellone ma se
non è sbagliato perché se uno cade left
form on time quella di prima ragazzi per
prendere la corona e vincere in 9 molto
difficile con una possibilità su 9 di
vincere sempre in finale arrivo è
comunque però il finale va tanto come
l'orario vediamo non è detto
tornati valori pazzesca e sarò bravo il
culo
mammamia ma perché non capita mai agli
altri ho perso per forza perché qua come
perdi un metro diverso
non credo di aver minuti tra di cinema
questo mi viene adesso avrà che
rincoglionito e vorrei ritiene sono
convinto invece no ma tenuto da è andata
bene questa è peccato perché potevo
vincerla peccato potevo andar potevo
dire questa era la vince peccato perché
alla fine è andata bene però se cadi in
sette sedili in sé bill edili bloccato
mezza volta diverso perché comunque sui
nove persone muro non verrà mai bloccato
quindi non puoi vincere come viene
bloccato poi le star e secondo me poi
non lo fare perché magari uno poi si
addormenta
però se vieni fermato al fall monte in
cui le star e hai perso perché tanto uno
arriva seguirà quindi non puoi vincere
però sempre finale un sacco di punti
minchia ragazzi sono pieno riguarda
quanti cacchio di voti show perché
arrivo sempre in finale ne guarda quante
io posso già sbloccarmi volendo il ninja
che è tantissimo mi bloccò il ninja
larga tanto ma si dai vi faccio l'india
che non è male però è difficile perché
tipo questo già epic per sbloccarlo devi
devi avere tutti istituti per prenderli
devi arrivare tante volte in finale io
ci arrivo sempre mi preme punti non sono
problemi
la corona è difficile ne ho due ho vinto
due volte e basta ciao ragazzi ciao a
tutti che hanno generato la live finirà
appena vi linko quindi tv
poi ci sono io che registra il dottore
in fila ma tanto e rimane da live rimane
alla live rimane la live quindi il
registro anch'io rimane online sul
canale tutta livesey sei morto
ma non fa niente tanto unosunove
impossibile ragazzi c'è ma va veramente
aq lo saprò di lottare per la vittoria
quando arrivò alla scalata finale e sono
tra i primi due o tre allora li dico 20
ragazzi posso vincere se no se partiamo
in nove per me è un mini gioco con un
altro finale niente veramente arrivare
primi ragazzi qua non cambia niente sono
dei punti e punti che ti dà alla fine la
partita serata viene da comunque non
troppissimo ad unirsi
la prima il primo la possiamo superare
questa cazzo di elica
eh no non possiamo va bene va bene
grazie
gentili non lo so
madonna con botte con bordello raga
aiuto perché ho il tempismo di mia nonna
ok a posto andiamo da culo e iori culo
non lo ebbi l'incarico al limite ragazzi
se arriva squadra perché amica sono
cascato 67 volte sul ragazzo di para ma
perché quale fa
noia noia puglia puglia povero pollo è
rimasto è rimasto lì e non entra
mi dispiace quando in finale salta
sempre negozio
allora mi capito studiassero saltare
sempre non vuol dire che vi fa andare
più veloce mi fa andare più recensiti in
piano se siete in discesa e voi saltate
state scendendo esaltate il vostro
personaggio prende la discesa fa un po
di slittamento quindi prendete velocità
se siete in salita no segue saltati in
salita si incaglia quindi non vale
sempre vale in discesa in piano in
salita non saltate vi rallenta a non ho
messo il ninja sono scemo l'ho comprato
uno emesso cos'è hanno visto cos'è tony
gatlif il set che cassano ma
allora che possa non l'ho mai fatta non
so cosa sia solo dire che ti devi
prendere la gente a minchia non si è
quindi devo prendere le persone minchia
metà persone vengono eliminate ma
veramente madonna che profitto mi gioco
che ansia poi con eliminate per metà
persone porca trottola e tantissimo devo
prendere le persone non ho mai non so
come questo non so niente
l'ho preso a quindi quando in sole
persone male pensando ma non so come sia
possibile
io devo passare agli altri no non ho
capito che cazzo con una non ho capito
non ho capito niente non nota non ho
capito niente
e accaduto appena pescato dietro pure 20
eliminati ragazzi non ho capito nulla
devi essere impegnata a ok è un infected
le major infetta il cielo avuto solo
alla fine quindi come infettato gli
altri specialmente c'è uno che parte con
le fette te devi infettare gli ha quindi
io devo sapere per i cazzi miei
ok non lo sapevo non avevo mai fa mai
fatta mai mai quello non lo so che non
avevo idea ragazzi quindi va bene vedi
che quando non sai come giocare ci sta
per un meta persone eliminate sono
veramente tante eroga o questo raro
questo comune e questo ninja che i mega
epico cioè epico basso sale leggendarie
secondo me quello il fucile è
leggendaria non lo so vorrei prendere
una corona al governo lo sapevo il fumo
rosati infetta non lo sapevo non avevo
idea bellissimo che bello non vorrei
giocarla perché adesso so come si gioca
non l'avevo mai fare penso sia l'unica
penso sia l'unica che ho giocato senza
sapere come si gioca
credo perché è fatta season questo
difficilissimo allora queste sono pedane
che scambiano dipendenza in base a
quante cose ci sono sempre bisogna
arrivare alla fine è un percorso a
ostacoli quindi molto difficile
bella con leggins e bisogna solo capire
dove farla per bene perché non sono
stato
sapevate che 26 caldi perché di
bastonare la prima volta perché è
lamentato però quando tutti fanno peso
cade dovuto e non puoi farci niente
prova di qualche c'è dipendenza o e
bueno che uno che arrivato alla fine
come cazzo è arrivato perché dopo quello
che arriva prima e stacca gli altri come
molto più avvantaggiato quanta pendenza
ce la fa che culo ce l'ho fatta ok
questo è veramente difficile perché
dipende da quanta gente sta sulle pedane
ragazzi c'è veramente un casino
poi comunque le pedane che abbiano di
dipendenza da sola è minimo aumenta la
difficoltà
ok suonando molto bene ovviamente se
dice poi interno riparti all'inizio
decadi per tutti
non so una tattica migliore bisogna
attendere e vedere quale la pendenza
ciao non ha senso i video più politica
cambia aspettavano perché la gente
aspetta lì che arrivino gli altri poi va
al traguardo troppo non ha senso per
evitare la vita lento stabilito speriamo
che non miei mi perché poi vi si riduce
a icona gioca un problema allora abilità
la modalità lenta ragazzi
ok eccoci qua non dà vita lenta che
adesso potete scrivere tutti
ci sono un sacco di pepe voleva la
guarda ho vinto un'ora fa ho vinto
quanto quanto tempo è che ho vinto
sarà un minuto buono e ancora sono a
metà player ci pensa quanto
l'allenamento comunque suo gioco fatto
perché quanti cacci di player ancora
sono lì che stanno poi si sta
qualificati o non è mai successo
dell'azione praticamente attivato la
modalità lenta ragazze se non lo so
sembra più lento avete del tempo però si
sono molto cattive ma infatti ragazzi
secondo me se loro lo schemi come come
già compromesso se stavo soprattutto
dicono praticamente niente
raga potete abbonarvi contrasta bonati
da qua sotto che vi saluto e ci sono
vari perché potete vedere è il tosto
super chat di fianco al solito si
portava in una donazione che comunque mi
son dimenticato cosa stava sì io spero
che lo aggiornino con tantissimi
videogiochi noi perché il potenziale
visto gioco infinito
se stanno già lavorando a dei nuovi
minigiochi questo gioco nel 2030 ancora
ci stiamo giocando negativo lo dico uno
di quei giochi che non muore mai
perché è aggiornato non muore mai ecco
la gittata di nuovo mi chiama me l'ha
mai successo due volte di fila pazzesco
sono un ninja pollo comunque io sono
diventato perché sono un ninja con la
moda bellissimo e naruto praticamente
guarda sono un filo cacchio può già una
guerra che la coda e il ninja mangiano
tutti e non è male a veri quelli sono
jeans e book
l'obiettivo è rimanere se tu rimani
senza essere
infettato per un bel po e meglio perché
comunque tutti però la videocamera
perché comunque l'obiettivo è non è
tanto infettare gli altri quanto
rimanere senza linfa ed quindi se io
rimango senza l'infestante faccio
vincere la mia squadra perché un punto
fa la differenza ok difetta giallo
liberavo occhio che lasciano i better a
saperlo prima gara gore caccia vacca con
i punta teloni puntate che puntano tutti
ma che cazzo vuoi da me ma perché tutti
ne è stato fatto io
meno male che a fuggire nella cavicchio
corato manca 66 siamo cimadon 2
infettate infettate
tra i violenti io l'unico di ma ragazzi
mi hanno issato fine abbiamo perso e io
sono rimasto l'unico abbiamo perso e io
sono rimasto l'unico senza essere
linciato non è meritocratico stava bene
ci sta perché da un po di varietà il
gioco però ho una nuova moto la mettiamo
vediamo che vediamo c'è una final hop in
europa i bambini nuovamente grazie per
la hbo nazione e thomas's international
che da anni e grazie mille per la
nazione sono arriva su un ultimo
infettato ultimo totalmente ultimo e non
ho vinto quindi coi team val culo 50 per
cento
l'iva veramente poi essere anche il
miglior john paese le ninja di four
nights ma perdi perché malerba della
squadra non validate però figo
l'importante è che qui io sono stato il
migliore è ancora stato nazione si dice
ah boh nazione la mente un amico mio non
so anche se da te sei già abbonato
la serie ha iniziato a funzionare no
alterandolo joystick ancora nato che
sfortuna no no ma prima e quando sei in
team e uno contro uno siamo al 50 per
cento ragazzi 50 per cento dei player
viene
minato un conto è se tu giochi per i
cacchi tipo l'inizio anche qua qua si
qualificano in 33 e partono in se siamo
in 60 e si qualificano in 30 quindi
anche qua il 50 per cento dei player
viene eliminato ma qua io dipendo da me
stesso se io vengo eliminato è colpa mia
non è colpa degli altri
se sono un team contro un team se vengo
eliminato è colpa del mio team non mia
io ho giocato da dio
io ero rimasto l'unico non infettato
quindi non è colpa mia li ho giocato io
ho giocato sono stato il migliore di
tutta la partita lì insieme ad una altri
12 dei gialli che erano primi che ci
hanno atteso per un punto però sono
stato il migliore però sosta terminato
lo stesso quindi preferisco di gran
lunga quando eliminano metà player ma tu
conti solo per te stesso ma che sei
conti per la squadra io con la fortuna
che mi ritrovo ferro perché la mia
squadra fa cagare
non mi rappresenta in viene in genere
poi la partita di coppa tribunali
credermi fatto finora era molto buona
profumo by lo so se può essere poi ci
può stare ma avrebbe senso si potrebbero
farle uscire due non credo sia questa è
una cosa che non ho capito non so se
anche uno splash forma non credo perché
quando bottino di 8 mila invece su
playstation no non lo so
quando fai la wing spero adesso spero
adesso ragazzi vedi qua metà player
eliminati dalla partenza
molti hanno lottato molti invece noi
vengono eliminati del tabellone
però io conto per me stesso se fossi
stato in una squadra magari sarei stato
eliminato perché la mescola lavativo è
che doveva
[Musica]
yes perché a me che sono con la pec all
plus mi dice che non è gratis
molto strano perché l'ho preso gratis
stamattina voglia di servire ieri sera
ieri se esce fermo poi viene rovinato
tantissimo non lo so ma penso magari una
versione solo per mobili nicodemo anche
wind e giacomo frate aurum
grazie mille collaborazione fratello
grazie mille
no sto dicendo secondo me se esce per
mobile e rimane mobili nel senso che non
è cross platform è che quelli col mobile
giocano con quegli la play 1 sola
ragazzi non è un'idea in così tanti
siamo si tratta lo vediamo sempre la
tattica di prima
no ci sta ha voluto strafare ci stava ci
sta ci sta
ho voluto ho voluto strafare e ci
stavano bene l'eliminazione totale
avviene dopo la prima dopo il primo
round tutti gli atti land viene
eliminato totalmente quindi questo round
non ha senso andare veloce perché tanto
arrivi alla fine io sono voluto andare
veloce perché voluto traiano tra yard
ato trai andato ho solo trai andato ci
sta a tanto dall'inizio
non serve andare veloce li by light
vinci però se vuoi tra yard aree poi
perdi perché che discrica delle
fortissime potrai are dato ci stava ci
sta basta che vai lento e no ragazzi se
non tra jardi non sei youtuber non
vedrei male io gioco per vincere qua ma
anche per toglier dare però adesso che
sono in live giochiamo per vincere
se vince oggi non me ne vado ai numeri
quando uno stacco di qua finché non vi
come nessun patto le palle gol
questo è uno dei preferiti in assoluto
fermo beni che un sacco di gente si
schianta poi le cambiare subito sono
motivi vantaggio io che aspetto non si
sfonda niente salafita guarda che sono
già quasi primo e o solo aspettato sono
andate qua stondate questo nemmeno
questo si espongano punto che spiega e
con uno spettacolo non ho aspettato vedi
quanto mai vedi quanto perdo se non
aspetto devi aspettare gli altri
piuttosto fermati e aspetta che tirano
partire non facciate gli altri aspetti
perché non vale niente avrà luogo una
regione aiuto vabbè mica pop corn siamo
ciao
[Applauso]
ma se aspetti non puoi perdere
cioè non si chiama fuga i ragazzi
miglior gioco del mondo chiamate tutti
non semplice vedere questa line perché
sarà leggendaria questo qua è come il
primo episodio di happy wings pensate
che è arrivato sul mio canale ha visto
il primo episodio di etica fenomeno era
lì qua lui era lì quando c'era il primo
episodio bis oggi voi siete qui con il
primo episodio di paul guys
questo è il primo e voi siete qua questo
è meraviglioso nome perché ve lo
ricorderete vi ricorderete questo
momento perché for guys stage non è che
deve spaccare spaccare sta già spaccando
for guys scaricatissimo ovunque quindi
sta spaccando e fare un miliardo di
episodi che mi piace fare che andranno
bene quindi io mi auguro che vadano bene
però mi piace quindi lo porterò comunque
è comunque piace tanta gente
sappiate che ci saranno un miliardo gli
episodi tipo è pp quindi voi siete i
primi a vederlo chiamate tutti i vostri
amici perché saranno qua potranno dire
io ero lì il primo episodio iv al guy's
di valigie perché col guys ragazzi lo
farò sempre non come quelli che ci sono
beni che sono primo sapete perché perché
vi mette più avanti quando arrivate
quando ho fatto un pò risultato prima
fatto un buon risultato prima mi ha
fatto un buon risultato
comincia come ho rischiato ho rischiato
e ragazzo ho fatto un buon risultato
prima e mi mette primo perché sennò non
sarebbe meritocratica stalla natura
oltre a davide che gli anche doppiamente
un errore sarà il traguardo per fare lo
sborone alla fine perché ti metteva il
biglietto vabbè che le file sono lunghe
quindi primi sono in dieci però sempre
meglio prima un esposto è veramente figo
ragazzi se gioca ipnotico ci avete
ragione perché ogni tanto di tuffi
perché tuffarsi in avanti ragazzi sempre
perché siete più veloci e durate vip in
aria
ce lo spawn
e che cazzo però non prendo non prenderò
mai più la pedana non serve c'era lo
sfogo in solo sei nato per sempre
tuffarsi in avanti e ragazzi quando non
arrivate al al punto è utilissimo perché
guarda fate un metro in più che utile
anche qua ecco se non mi fossi tuffato
non
non sarei arrivato ecco un altra roba
come fa la gente ad afferrarmi che non
mi ha appreso resta molto dietro e via
ferro uguale meno male che non c'era la
limina tale eliminazione diretta che
sarebbe stato un problema ragazzi qua
avrei perso due volte
aspetto il millesimo gioco di episodio
di folgaria ragazzi nel 2030 ci sarà il
millesimo di faul guys io fare un sacco
di jolo non lo sostituisca le prime foto
anche questa che più sta a me piace ed è
bello e ultimamente non è neanche
ripetitivo perché ho trovato a vi
ricordo ragazzi che domenica prossima e
domenica prossima ancora ci sono episodi
199 e 210 sono due speciali bellissimi
vedrete sarà incredibile ma faremo io
non lo sostituirò happy meal self
organized ci mancherebbe però lo porterò
spessissimo spessissimo intendo due
volte alla settimana almeno almeno
vorrei diventassero 3 vorrei
diventassero tremore importarlo lunedì
mercoledì e venerdì
per adesso lo schedulato lunedì e il
giovedì se va bene lo porto tre giorni
parente challenge delle partite normali
certo ragazzi faremo un miliardo di
robert gates è troppo bello e troppo un
gioco incredibile
domani non perdetevi il video che esce
di faul guys perché l'ho già fatto ed è
il primo video su paul guys quindi ci
sono io che provo a giocare senza sapere
come si gioca quindi mi vedrete meno
esperto di adesso però merita perché la
mia prima partita su folger merita
merita perché la mia prima partita e vi
faccio vedere come sono stato bravino
anche nel mio primo bar alla ciliegia
una mela ok banana banana mela banana me
la ciliegia a cuba ok lamela ci sarà la
cinese uguale non ci vediamo perché
meno bene ha fatto a cadere quello che
pirla la gente ancora si basa sul
proprio intelletto ma statevi secondo
degli altri nell arancia uva cuba
anguria paranà melarancia uova anguria
mela manciata di manduria melarancia una
miglioria melarancio anguria melarancia
una nuria melarancia un'anguria
melarancio mangoni a banana me la fa ma
adesso tutti si sono fidati di me
cadiamo penso se si fidavano tutti di me
e cade a regalavano tutti bellissimo
credo anche guardiamo se ciò seccato
anche stavolta che gli viene eliminata
poca gente perché secondo me andiamo
ragazzi io l'ho detto sto gioco qua non
ha senso perché eliminano pochissime
persone
pochissime si sono mai fatti secondo me
ai ragazzi una tasca da te un deficiente
una tattica
secondo me sarebbe
[Musica]
cercare di rimanere su una piattaforma
sbagliata così quando quando quando esce
il frutto tutti butti sono piattaforma
sbagliata e poi tutti su quella giusta
qui siamo tutti ti seguono e poi tu la
cambi perché secondo me l'unica perché
non lo so mi sembra utile fa mi ammazzo
ragazzi bello averlo l'abergo resta
faccio schifo io nella frutta cadente
faccio schifo non mi piace proprio
rimango a lato cerco di evitare il
massimo della frutta però la gente mi
cade puntualmente addosso è la frutta me
la prendo in faccia tutta quindi la vedo
perché culo va bene va bene
vedi rimani a lato e io non sono bravo
in questo e se fossi bravo arrivare pure
primo ma in questo faccio schifo ma
vinco sempre perché rimane la lato è
utilissimo perché al centro casca il
trombo queste persone alleva di cadere
perché quintano già prima certo per only
a prescindere in quel mini gioco cadono
meno persone che in un gioco normale
veri qua anche quando le stato persone
però vedi che nel tabellone cadono di
più quello di prima certo che cade gente
prima e les tano e secondo me da pixar è
sta roba che non dovrebbe farla vedere
come nel cartellone che più bello però è
molto utile cambiarlo perché poca gente
secondo me al senso che facciamo la roba
lì perché tutti si buttano sulla stessa
piattaforma
alla fine tra quattro eliminati non di
più finale vediamo io porto nel mezzo vi
neanche troppo bene però vedo male
vediamo di andare dove c'è meno gente a
questo punto dove si sposta la gente di
spostarmi lì allora la gente sembra
andare a destra o da sinistra
penso
ho perso perché sicuramente qualcuno non
verrà colpito vedi basta una volta una
volta ragazzi a quella a meno che quello
non sei un pirla totale ho perso
mannaggia vera che è arrivato quarto
vinto ma non puoi cadere mai ma è
comunque che adesso ha perso è
difficilissimo melarancio l'anguria
melarancio l'anguria devi fare così
ragazzi così si può giocare con altri sì
e sapete che mi sto chiede stiamo
chiedendo se si potevano fare sempre
privati adesso chiederò ai ragazzi che
hanno sviluppato secondo si possono fare
sere privati devono provare giocati con
pochi sarebbe figo fare tutti quanti
anche se vi focus e rete tutti quanti
per uccidermi quindi non altro un senso
però per provare quante volte hai vinto
due volte ragazzi lo vedete la le corone
comprende sono queste ho vinto già due
volte non registrate però perché ho
giocato per i cacchi miei ho registrato
un video che il primo che ho registrato
che vedrete domani
[Musica]
basta domani non vedere non mi vedrete
così esperto perché vi ripeto ho giocato
tanto so so come si giocherà però odio
quando intel taglio parola va dalla fine
a chi lo dici fratello è già successo
due volte
e difficilissimo arrivare alla colonna
finale che sa dipende dalle partite
perché sul monte in quella di prima
se l'avessimo fatta in 78 magari la
variante vinta in 15 in finale sono
tanti tanti agenti di come arrivare come
arrivare primo qua non è la stessa cosa
per occupa comunque è una probabilità
infima il confronto di arrivare primi
qua è difficilissimo tu devi arrivare
contro pochi persone perché almeno ai
probabili possibilità quando eravamo in
finale a quello della coda erano mi6 li
avrei preferito fare la scalata perché
lei a l'avrei vinta perché sono
bravissimo nella scalata però se siamo
in 15 basta chiesti intoppi mezza volta
hai perso perché un altro basta che non
siete offline bardawil veri cioè questi
che sono più avanti
qua ci se ne frega arrivare primo però
vedere se questa fosse stata la finalità
diverse perché c'è troppa gente che
compete qui la finale o la fai in sei
madonna quanto tempo per rialzarmi gli
va bene ma no ma no buon occhio per i
nice
sempre tra i primi cinque
comunque io qua veramente sono un penale
inizio non c'è pro verso nessuno mib
abate e rais inc
dietro non sono sempre il dott il gioco
della memoria lo considerano molto buono
perché fai punti proprio perché non
vorrei essere ok
sì è un punto di vista a me di fare
tutti non mi interessa molto perché io
arrivo sempre in finale cioè no non è
vero
arrivò quasi sempre in finale perché me
la cavo
quindi a me che quel gioco lo facciamo
meno me ne sbatto anzi perché poi è un
round in meno quindi in finale ci sarà
più gente capito quindi io voglio
vincere
quindi io preferisco che non ci sia però
è vero che se la guardi sotto l'ottica
dei conti si è utile che ci stia
guardando perché lo vincono tutti i
guadagni di subiti ma a me non piace
perché i punti di guadagno uguale perché
me la cavo su sto gioco quindi
preferisco che venga mia tuta più gente
hai vinto una volta una corona te la dà
il pass se dopo vai a vedere nel passo
lo vedi che senso lamela già da io ce
l'ho già le colonne da 2 up su sky.it
scramble egg scramble ragazzi è
bellissimo siamo in tre team il team
vince viene eliminato quello che ha meno
uova quelle tre uova gialle valgono tipo
5 nuovo vale 1 devo viaggiare valgono 5
l'obiettivo è portare più uova possibile
le gialle vai vai se la mia squadra
senza siamo tutti la stessa squadra
calmi tutti in ascesa squadra porto io
porto io porto io bravo quello giallo
vale tanto è portiamoli ora vi spingilo
dei mostri o dentro ci sono uno di blu
con una mia che cazzo e dai modi con
l'ex pci come cosa c'è uno blu porta la
foto il portale già il portone già come
l'inizio bravo o cotone uno in difesa
allora ragazzi qua due o tre dentro il
cesto in difesa tutti perché se qua
perdiamo punti veliche che la gente poi
tra del tuo cestino provare votato
sempre qualcuno in difesa sempre il
resto rimane difesa perché solidi
compagni non ci stanno rimango io fa
niente però sempre in difesa perché se
non sta in difesa la gente ti ruba le
uova soprattutto quelle rose gialle che
vedo li porterà giu bravo
sempre in difesa ragazzi sempre solo in
difesa perché se non ha senso gli altri
stanno attaccando spero perché non vedo
può arrivare adesso le vedo bravi voi
dovreste farvi care a tra di voi
i blu ei rossi dovrebbero farsi gara tra
di loro invece li vedo qui per quale
motivo perché io li vedo qui dovrebbero
farsi chiara tra di loro perché quello
che ha più punti deve rimanere
ma se voi verrà giocate con i rossi non
con noi siamo primi la giocate con i
rossi che cazzo vuoi da noi
ok grazie sono state mi faceva le palle
che non lo sarò mai
ok e lia faco commenta giacomo mail
brother grazie mille il nuovo normale
non fa niente
tra virgolette però i rossi non hanno
veramente capito che dovevo dare
compreso il 14 che non hanno speranza
è un accanimento totale per forza grazie
mille per la donazione caro un uomo di
leggo venti secoli file topanga commenta
giacomo vecchio somma cc n go non ne hai
vinta un anno vinte due però non nella
live quindi non s'è visto vorrei farvela
vedere che carino quando vinci working
at pusher che questa è quella della
rocca laurent arrivare primi io sono io
prediligo chi arriva primo perché chi
arriva primo la palla va arrotolarsi già
nel nella porta e devi prendere la
parola all'altro sarei di prima e meglio
perché almeno tutto un della giochi
questa la giocano gli altri due vice pin
gente ci ammazzano tra di noi ragazzi
siamo nusco andrà dritti dritti quello
va già in avanti bravo uno sempre avanti
uno a pasta anche solo uno avanti gli
altri a spingere bravo bravo ok 50 per
cento
i rossi sono quasi più avanti non lo
sappiamo
66 rossi dovrebbero bloccare in lui
tu che sei secondo devi bloccare il
terzo non in primo anche il primo non lo
blocchi l'altro veniva adesso tu sei
stupido rosso di perdere uno perde non
lo bello persa ma recupero dopo
tranquilli grazie mille comunque per la
donazione a lezione di paul rice
questo almeno un gioco che so fare e
kakà temi so fare solo questo una corona
te l'ha data il pass e una l'hai vinta
no pippo junkie tomanin da giacomo no
perché io l'ho vinta una anche sulla
playstation 3 c'è sì qua no due però noi
o con lo stesso gioco cielo sulla play
con un altro account
ho vinto la corona lì poi lo sto dicendo
gabriele rossi era perdonami nota ho
visto
grazie mille elaborazione ora dopo
quindi sono tre corone capito cosa sto
dicendo tu quale 22 web perché sono
anche sulla play
ho vinto due volte una corona per la
data al massimo non so perché ho quindi
non 4 di corone perché una mela verrà
data anche sulla playstation di passo
forza ragazzi quanto siamo come siamo
distribuiti qua siamo in quattro e
lasciavano in 23 meno di là vado li dava
sempre non uscite dal mica siamo
veramente pochi i ragazzi ma che cazzo
fate genova la metà li ho fatti io
ragazzi dai forza sempre un minuto e
mail eventi quindi tutto da fare però
tutti bulli giorno mi butto sul lato dai
centro però che cazzo a cui ha fatto
quello on usi sì l'ha mancato meno male
la mancata lui ecco l'ho preso io sono
fortissimo e va beh quello che in realtà
non è poi accompagnare compaiono altro
dai da lancia di lancia di tutti ma c'è
di più
non ridete marin davide c'è un 5
nola preso il giallo quel pezzente
schifoso maledetto colorato niente io
non questo film questo prenderlo perché
prendono con i limiti
torno perso che qua non c'è niente
sicura www e giallo non è giallo
mannaggia siamo primi marca 24 secondi
sono troppi gli lasci sono già quattro
blocchi o bello quello che un quinto ben
34 jaguar sa che basta un giallo per
portare i rossi la vittoria non cedete
non cedete ora padrón frodo
non cedete ora che non escono più dai
dai dai costi campi di cose ok si è
schiantato giallo mo gaza
ho detto notato dal dato delle botte con
il coccige che fanno vivere il pro del
naso quando lo faccio
dodici le mening vi prego non fatemi
fare una finale adesso che 12 sono
ancora troppi non una finale rocket
league
ti prego non fare no no
no senza pensa presse presente già f3
mente già f.to per respect l'olivo già
manager mi tufferò su questo di bianco
ma davanti al mio amico quindi non serve
a niente sorpasso sulla piattaforma
gioco ma bisogna trovare una tattica
la tattica giusta e non è roteare
completamente 66 volte come un budino
questo che invade sbarra la strada ei
bello che gli altri giocano terrona
premi le palle io non gioco per rompere
le palle agli altri su questo c'è io
veramente vorrei commentare ma non
commento ragazzo vorrei commentare tutto
questo non lo come però potrebbe esserci
una tattica utile isolarmi
la tattica di isolarsi non è male
secondo me cetica di subito hd subito e
ti tagli già tutto il percorso in modo
tale da rimanere l'unico non è male però
la tattica giusta a scendere all'ultima
caricare un buco al centro non è male
per sempre sagola pippo già quito manco
come in the giacomo my brother non è
male con la tattica effettivamente per
quanto comunque non è facile per questo
centro è fare il giro non è mondo nè non
è semplicissimo secondo me avere un
attimo
scusate che trova nel batte il passo
manette il trigger ato me l'ha data il
battevo capito però quindi cielo anche
di là quindi io ne ho quattro litri
totale di corona sembra da tanti di laio
vinto 2 volte 2 watt e il pass con tale
vittoria non quelle col batte il passi
col bate bassa butt.butt impasse è
gratis
ebbene frega infatti la skin che voglio
prendere io e difficile proprio perché a
tre corone quindi devi vincere almeno
due volte sia questo il nuovo format e
lo pensano di maio pensano un po tutti
lotta perché ha avuto un'esplosione è
uscito tre giorni fa lo giocano tutti
cioè è veramente il per i giocatori del
mondo attualmente
con i sul port de vita al centro allora
decidete di ora mi concentro vito
secondo me la tattica giusta e cioè
correre sul centro per toglierlo agli
altri poi andare sul bordo però non
manca uno questo per la scuola ma vedi
che saltare in discesa aumenta la
velocità ragazzi adesso sono caduto però
in modo nuti affidate questo sembra
ragazzi non so se lo fa anche a me vi
ricorda la pista tik tok di mario kart e
lo fa solo a me ragazze mi sembra la
pista tik tok di mario kart dai dai
i temi che non sono numeri
la palla è odiosa ok
pensate se fanno poi le mappe
personalizzate tipo gta 5 sto gioco
infinito più le mappe originali che
continuano a creare i creatori sto gioco
e finire associato infinito fidate
infinito
raga la pista tik tok questo ha finito
con la di super mario kart e quella è
proprio quella roba mai vista
vedi tra i primi cinque normale se fanno
ma personalizzate sarebbe troppa infatti
le mettono custom nel senso metti poi
delle ricerche mappe casco non appena un
casco a pisa ha detto primario carta
ragazzi e degli orologi ci sono per
terra che non gli devi scrivere fanno
esattamente questa cosa
saltare per consumare meno strada è ok
però la strada che non consumi la usano
gli altri capito che si che se la palla
ma poi prendono guarda io veramente vi
giuro io io la mia vita la capisco prima
ancora che avvengano le cose
quei due si sono sono fatti sono stupidi
perché sono gravati a vicenda della sede
siamo primi siamo primi e nel mentre poi
uno non toglieva la presa dall altro e
sarà eliminato i bravi complimenti
complimenti ricorda takeshi's castle
esatto che ridere
tim dal team del taglio che è questo
quello delle cose
vince tinca più cose cioè viene
eliminato il team con meno comode una
possibilità su 20 c o il 25 per cento di
possibilità di essere minato ragazzi
come quando dipende da me e il mio team
perché io che so bravo lo so il mio team
se va a cagare
cos'è che posso staccare la corrente
dove vai
io te voglio di qua fratello si pensi di
poter andare spiegano ai crediti andare
infrante posso credere ma dove mai si
mette anche due e mezzo dai la facciamo
tutti insieme tranquillo no no io voglio
lui fa niente no no no no lasciamo il
rosso
io ce l'avevo con lui non contento di
questi sono da tempo e verde è un
peccato quando che lì per terra perché
non era poi può fare niente se non
perdere la coda subito perché cari per
terra e poi dati della gravano istant
questo è fermo totti ma tattica rimanere
fermi perché far credere di essere fk ma
non sei altro
se non è sbagliato mediche e funziona
passare nel martello mega utile se no ci
rimani saturato degli altri non spazzati
via sbagliato sbagliato o no no ok
madonna meno male 33 secondi è ancora
totali e da chi insomma spoleto né mi
chiamavo visto con la coda quello che
pirla colpa mia ho sbagliato bisogna per
la nazione caro ho sbagliato io pensavo
fosse con la cosa davvero la voglia
detto ehi questo qua se fosse stato un
altro io la coda già non ce l'avevo più
perché quando gli altri mi chiamano
migravano km invece gli altri un
chilometro non riesco aggravarli cazzo
di devo dire io più che giocarla bene
adesso non vi so dire perché ragazzi io
l'ho giocata newman dal mio meglio
totale i miei compagni non hanno questa
va culo comunque il 25 per cento
hai una possibilità su quattro di essere
minato può pensare fortemente ora va la
tua
ma la tua squadra puoi giocare anche
bene ricorda un foglio manchette lontana
dicono a me ricorda più gang beast vi
ricordate gang beast però non no non
tanto maggiore perché è una qualità di
gioco diversa qualora un figlio
guarderai milionesimo episodi polgai 3
di lee che avrò visto il primo episodio
esatto è il milionesimo episodio mi sa
che lo guarda il tuo ambito avo antenato
no sbagliato traversi kafka vacca questa
non ho mai fatta quando si va fatta
prima che questa è altra cosa normale e
sono le difese sempre la discesa ragazzi
saltate in discesa che prendete una
velocità pazzesca è veramente utile
poi non capisco perché quando scrivo io
non sono disposto alle 9 si esprime in
bagno
pertanto ogni volta che il mio cazzo di
personaggio non corre corre ma non è
solo negli altri amici che ti entra in
testa mamma mia a benedet vero ragazzi
assomiglia un po a me land and vive ma
viva e non la fa
non lo so chissà se l'ha fatto più di
poi non penso non credo non credo ne
vita ho alcuna novità e due ragazzi per
adesso va a culo perché alla fine
vincono tutti a culo sto gioco non va
la finale il resto no la finale dal culo
anche qua io posso cercare io so come si
gioca sui miei compagni fanno schifo non
è colpa mia io ci provo allora siamo i
gialli va bene io rimango in difesa
perché in difesa non rimane nessuno
quindi anche voi siate bravi si è
giocata su gioco rimanete in difesa
perché la difesa della signoria con un
cinema con tutti e alle famiglie
grazie che nota yen che sono max abbiamo
quattro palle ottimo abbiamo avviato una
merda ok rimangono difesa di
tranquillità cui dal pisa quindi che
sarà già lo è diventato va bene c'è un
blu tranquillo perché il mio tuffo non
vale niente
ok go fermo questo bene very nice
sono solo in difesa riporta l'importante
è che lì ma non sono io c'è chi parla te
che vogliate in partita grazie ai
carotaggi per le donazioni da 3000 il
nostro cielo importante che rimangano
gli altri attaccare perché io sono
l'unico in difesa quindi se io sono un
in difesa siamo in dieci in squadra io
sono in difesa io sono in difesa
nove sono in attacco e dove sono le
palle e quindi questo è quindi fate bene
l'attacco se io sono in difesa
questo è solo e ne va bene va bene molto
bene
tengo qua io è che queste rotolano bene
pensate
no occhio lì a occhio lì che l'abbiamo 4
ma rischiamo bravissimo ragazzo un buon
team
come l'ho vinto le partite allora novità
una con la scalata quella della corona
quella che arrivi alla fine le percosse
vinci
eravamo in sette è un'altra l'ho vinta
con la coda la cosa che devi tenere per
ultimo contenuta per la maggior parte da
un come l'hanno rubata per le rubata
ieri nuovo vinto tipo quasi prima solo
che ho vinto
no non può andare avanti
competitivamente dipende dipende se
dipende in realtà non è relativa
politicamente la questione fatta in
faccia più spettatori di forte è uscito
altro ieri comunque no a parte quello
[Musica]
può andare a difendere la competitività
dipende perché le tattiche che andranno
a svilupparsi cambieranno gli esiti del
gioco tu conta che adesso giochiamo
tutti ed è uscito da tre giorni quindi
non sappiamo bene le tattiche neanche
noi
le ipotizzando io ipotizzo quali sono le
tattiche migliori che finora abbiamo
sempre aiutato cose private in finale
potrà nome la cava molto bene io sto
giorno quindi funziona però cioè non è
che già studiato lo sono affatto stai
fermo io qua non sono brava fan qua
allora quali sa che non sono bravo io
perché qua vengo eliminato sempre e gli
altri io vedo che resistono sempre come
cazzo fanno che comunque è veramente
difficile
non esser eliminati qua ci guarda non
cade nessuno è veramente difficile non
cadere fidatevi 4 ok a metà è veramente
difficile
fidatevi non cadere qua è difficile date
in questa parlamentali velocità ogni 4
secondi
ok 8 su 10
madonna yes yes vai vai a vedere a
problema
quindici le mail i we hope so speriamo
ragazzi speriamo che
no spiega non sia l'ultimo round questo
non mi mettere rocket iii che sapevo
perché mi metterà del mi metterà net
income la gente io so qual è quello con
meno gente 8 e 7 quello blu se vi
mettete il blu sono il team come la
gente io col culo che ciò finisco sempre
con quello meno cento vediamo no sono di
più
raga siamo uno in più occhio è non mi
fanno incazzare sahm1 in più basta è
meglio avere uno in più c'è meglio
essere in di meno e porti che in di più
e stupidi quindi ragazzi non siete
stupiti
siamo forti meraviglioso un in difesa
c'è meravigliosi bravi arriva la palla
occhio subito dylan la fabbrica che ti è
stato dato perfetto bravi bravi bravi
corretto e corrette e titti il bravo
cristiano ccr tette
occhio a nomi che non mi posso distrarre
un attimo non mi poi io valgo tutta la
squadra non è per tirarmela ma come mi
distraggo prendiamo gol non mi posso rie
siamo in tanti e non mi posso distrarne
perché la forma in come non ho preso la
palla al centro l'hanno presa gli altri
mannaggia bravi o così si fa che col
finché il tiro da metà campo fortissimo
bravi ok
ne avete fatto ricredere per il vostro
gradi prima mica come mi sono distratta
abbiamo preso gol pazzesco 6 madonna che
schiacciata
la v7
questa è una one hit ragazzi mi piace ho
dato una testata fortissima un blu o chi
a destra che siamo 7 a 2 ma non è finita
che quasi tv fermate sono cazzi brave
ben 82 dai più in difesa non sono bravi
questi la bravi che tiro che peraltro ha
scelti
ok via dieci gol quasi ai ragazzi mica
che record non mai fatto 10 gol speriamo
derivati che li facciamo perfetto in 10
10 gol e record mai fatti 10 giuro
tantissimi perché quando la pivano
schizza fortissima attenzione uno contro
uno
chen e 7 no la parata lo zio 11 gol
dovresti assegnato c'è sempre questo che
mi rompe le palle vieni stai fermo
arbitro trattenuta 12 rileva ben 13 gol
e ve lo riporto il viso si ma lasciate
bella è stato divertente e quindi fuori
alle palace o training gran finale c'è
uno che è una nostra ragazzi con il
basso questo qua lo vedete come si
chiama skin da anas che finale tanto per
cambiare settima finale 14 a 2
incredibile sul monte sono annunciato di
mezzo devo andare doveva meno gente però
è la spizzica non un sacco di persone
prima ma non dura molto ma [ __ ]
terza a meno che non siamo stupidi voi
due verso ma che cazzo facciano lei in
bot ste palle tutta me
speriamo che cadono quei due ragazzi di
una caduta
spero che si incastrano tra loro nome ma
va bene
[Musica]
next game o è saltato questo cos'è a è
un pezzo di tastiera di sotto ok
buono a sapersi non so come si dimette
perché mi sa che è rotto sotto la
tastiera nice
a nokia questo si può dimettere non si
può dimettere così anzi l'ho rimesso un
po sbilenca nice
ho rotto un pezzo nextgame che cazzo
ai ragazzi una finale non è una finale
in due una fila di 26 che il calcio
globale cioè come sbaglia una volta hai
perso 6 aiuto la peste calmo che sarà
per sempre se c'è un plus ragazzi che io
sappia serve per quello perché ho
scaricato solo con quello io prima
quindi credo che serva quello mi si è
rotto un pezzo della tastiera ma non so
dove sia finito
ho perso l angolo della scrivania vabbè
mi dispiace per la pastiera però andava
fatto perché non puoi prenderlo hanno
presente non può io poi lo dico io noi
ci ha osservati
be nice
la velina cazzo
ecco pixel
si può acquistare anche a 20 euro sulla
play ragazzi però se avete playstation
plus è gratis
ti conviene ok allora questo qua come vi
ho detto prima se volete tagliare tra
gli hard a tema non serve perché qua
basta arrivare alla fine non cambia
rivali primi niente quindi tranquillo
sangue
oddio mamma vacanze ma perche mi hanno
buttato giù e casinò in cosa sei lento
veloce con camilli prima ero il più
veloce ma sono stato eliminato perché
traiano d'altro
chi me lo fa fare ma è lento tanto basta
purificarsi chi me l'ha fatto fare
niente questo ma dovuto buttare giù che
cacchio vuoi da me
abbiamo da call of duty mano uscivano
usciva risottata uno sneijder ma cos'è
avrai perché diminuisce il counter
ragazzi perché sono quelli che lottano
perché sono troppo indietro e capiscono
che lavorando per le avrebbero persa e
le faq [ __ ] credibile
minchia
che cazzo fai che sta accadendo colpirla
per fermarmi c'è veramente
e per lo slam che vengono uccisi non
perché eletto anche perché l'etano 72
quando c'è lo slime credo che si muoia
sempre meglio adesso che ha dati tre
eliminati ma il natale eliminati in
molti di più nella mia di un sacco
dai dai ragazzi 30 rimanere nei dai può
essere quella buona
vediamo blog fuori parti è carino basta
stare avanti un pelo non si può
scaricare apc ragazzi su steam la
tastiera mia esploda punto manca il
presentatore che sbraita ogni prova se
non guarda che ci scalza entrate sono io
vuole brighton york
adesso sono io quindi è uguale a
takeshi's cast faccio il presentatore
grazie che mi chiedi fermo come se ti
servita da uk con queste di servizi a
vincere questa partita complimenti
ottima tecnica perché se sei primo
tirartela giochi più visti perché gli
altri stanno poi tutti a seguire in
merito ai a questo nuovo vista quali si
sono portati aiuto ago mi piacevano ma
beatbox di mandolini eccoci oggi io dio
no no no no che cazzo come ha fatto due
gol ma ok ma come qualcosa o poi così
come fatto a salire lì con la fatto c'è
uno che a salire e salito sopra ma cosa
come possibile manovale o un è salito di
sopra lì ma cos'è questa roba come basta
salire mie che bug minchia limiti un
sacco di persone
madonna qualche rimasto solo io pratica
bene interessiamo rima ragazzi conti
sono i passi sono il 4 e finale dopo 4 6
4 esperimento di mina tipo di questioni
che mi fermo oddio stava servendo
ragazzi di quattro ragazze un amico
nazionali copiosa min 4 tra cui uno che
è rimasto sul cornicione sa solo lui
come in quattro siamo quasi mai ma che è
successo
vabbè showdown colori ha varato infatti
non merita di stare drive ma non quello
che cade non quello che accade non
quello che bisogna checa di nonna quello
che non quello che cavi non quello che
cavi non quello che calcola la montagna
questa battaglia
[ __ ] fumble va bene ma ancora ben sa
ancora bene lo sa ancora bene non sarà
bene dai dai dai dai
chi è che la cosa a chi è che la cosa
chiara con la palla ce lo vedo comunque
quello che la cosa non vale che parla
che la fota insomma una cosa deve
restare deve stare nel centro perché se
no nel senso
diamogli la coda tra mentre doveva
perché quasi mi in pochi ragazzi è solo
fracchia bravo complimenti verde se il
fenomeno ha insegnato a giocare qua
ninja
sono caduto come buono perché quello che
parte con la coda vantaggia tissimo
siamo in quattro come cazzo fai da per
la coda ma perdo subito perché io certe
certo figurati io devo stare un
centimetro monetaria devono stare un
chilometro per prenderne come non è che
quando mai
ok
guarda che se la prenderà un chilometro
e scopeti sente male detto guarda è
prima resistito un minuto ed erano molti
di più speriamo di farlo stesso
un è fermo credo possa avere una tattica
quella maledetta sa che mi ha dato frega
no kat
dentro idiota
[Musica]
no
ctp di
chi se la merita sta partita
indipendentemente da chi vince provate a
dirlo più di buy se la merita
[Musica]
bene chi dove la scritta polgai win dove
è qua e qua questa la scritta resta la
scritta proprio lui la giustizia la
castiga li castiga è solo tre e ci
prendiamo la skin dal pugile dopo tre
ore ma comunque noi ragazzi artistica
sino a parte tutto serio fate gioca
trovata provateci e fatemi vedere quanto
ci mettete a vincere è difficilissimo
perché arrivare in finale e un casi nei
fatti non eravamo
me l'ha data la corona
[Musica]
scusa non ho capito scusa no no no va
bene e sa fare
la presa fin qua qua e cioè nel senso no
l'ance nascosti dietro i personaggi rati
gira titoli
noi ce la farò una riavvia riavvio o
fate scherzi e fate scherzi
bene bene va che bug e c'è meno bene va
bene standard e ne vado è finito me ne
fa io me ne vado no no qua parto quadri
denunce pace ritorniamo all'aiuto
vecchia denunce sud no eh
ma
[Musica]
cosa cosa ma va bambù ma per ragazzi
importante aver vinto poi vabbè io mi
devo dire non darà sciocco st corona
mela merito è mia
lo mando sto video lama domando a hanno
chiesto il parere guarda un po il parere
mio sono milano 26 corone ai cantori del
gioco in per rimpiazzare quella coperto
per scusarsi io mi incazzo
mando tutta la live mando tutta la ride
aprendo è la domanda che lasciato mando
tutta live
ora chi ha vinto guarda dove la corona
non c'è allora dài gliela mando a davis
per devi aspettare che i server a ok a
me l'aria ok demiri a ok ok ok quindi
server deve riavviarsi il server poi
minimi compare ok ma vengono quindi mi
unii miri compatta e successo anche a me
vi compare quando riavvia mi serve
perché c'è troppa gente che ci ha mica
perché pensavo non me l'avesse data
quindi me la darà più avanti cioè io
domani logo e mitra una corona in più
perché si riavviano da soli server
minchia per un attimo pensavo ma poi
perché scusami ma che sa che cosa che
appesantisce il server una corona
ma cosa va bene dai me la ridà la terza
vittoria raga ottimo
spero che vi sia piaciuto allora questo
apple guys questo è for guys
ripeto tornerò su fall guys tutti i
martedì non sfidare tutti i lunedì e
tutti i giovedì sul canale con un video
quindi lunedì a giovedì sul canale ci
sarà polgai tranne questa settimana che
lo metto anche già domani ok già domani
ci sarà un altro peso di folgaria che
sarà il mio primo episodio cioè nel
senso è la prima volta che ci ho giocato
quindi mi vedrete meno esperto di oggi
ok evidente meno esperto 3 bello vi
faccio vedere il mio primo impatto con
fall guys proprio carino farò tantissimi
episodi lunedì giovedì sempre sul mio
canale
guardatevi di tutti 40 di tutti i video
ma questi di folk merita perché saranno
spettacolari
quindi spero che video vi sia piaciuto
guardatevi volgari stesso cash vi
ringrazio per essere stati in live spero
che l'hai vi sia piaciuta ci vediamo
domani con fall guys colaprico il mio
primo match in volgare
niente un bacino grazie per essere stati
con me
niente ciao ragazzi il sì un next time
stato profilo bello che sarai
pomeridiana fatta extra perché altro non
so se questo mese ci sarà da il
pomeridiana perché forse siamo in
vacanza non lo so nel dubbio l'abbiamo
già fatta se ci sarà sarà un extra per
veniamo gatti intanto grazie per avermi
seguito